Vodafone. Nein, es ist kein Vodafone.
Es funktioniert und alles.
Ich muss bloß gucken, ob alles funktioniert.
Glocks HD in sieben Monaten. Dankeschön.
Pock es ab.
Max, du bist doch unabhängig von Toilettenpapier
mit meinem Superklo. Naja.
So einfach ist das Ganze auch wiederum nicht.
Ich meine,
ich zeige das Klo hier nochmal.
Ich meine, man...
Wer hat, der hat.
So ganz unabhängig davon.
A8000 plus.
So ganz unabhängig von
Klopapier bin ich auch nicht.
Ähm, denn...
Gibt es hier irgendwo ein schönes Bild von dem Klo?
Oh, was ist denn hier? Alter,
der Scam-Train ist schon wieder am Start.
Geht ja instant hier, Schlag auf Schlag hier.
Kio-Kund am Start, Stufe 1,
sind neun Monate am Start.
Huge Sub. Da kommt der Patrick hinterher mit
neun Monaten auch am Start.
Und der Hype-Train ist schon fast voll.
Der Scam-Train läuft, Leute.
Ähm,
ich überlege gerade, ob es...
Noch mehr hier. Der High-Noob, sechs Monate.
Ei, ei.
Ne, noch kein Sonntag.
So.
Und zu der Frage hin, ob ich abhängig...
Ob ich nicht... Hier sieht man es schön.
Unabhängig von Klopapier bin,
so einfach ist es nicht.
So einfach ist es halt nicht.
Also wie gesagt, das Klo hat ja hier
einen Föhn.
Und hier so eine Wasserdüse.
Man sieht das leider nicht, weil die sich der Meinung sind,
ah, hier doch.
Ah, kriegt man schön das Wasser
an Poppes.
Ähm, man sieht es ja auch.
Wobei, eigentlich können wir so sagen,
ich hab ja ein Video dazu gemacht.
Ja.
Kack-FPS.
Da hatte ich doch das alte iPhone.
So, und hier sieht man das jetzt.
Hier kommt gleich das Ding rausgefahren
und sprayt einem den Hintern ab.
Das ist schon 2013, das ist ewig lang her.
So, und neben kommt dann ein Föhn rausgefahren.
Ja, guck hier, da ist der Föhn.
Also, ähm,
ganz unabhängig von
Klopapier bin ich auch nicht, denn
Oh yeah.
75 Cent.
Dankeschön.
Ach, Bits
zählen da auch dazu.
Huge.
Ich hab heute übrigens nichts
Spezifisches vor.
Ähm, so, zumindest
ich bin nicht ganz unabhängig von
Klopapier, denn, guck mal, ich hab sogar
einen Forscher von meinem Video.
Ja, lustig.
Ähm, denn man braucht trotzdem noch ein bisschen Klopapier.
Erstens braucht man ein bisschen Klopapier ab und zu mal, um
schlicht und ergreifend, um hier ein bisschen sauber zu machen drumherum.
Und, wenn man, ich benutze den Föhn nicht.
Ich benutze, ich benutze den Föhn nicht.
Das heißt, ich lass mir den Bobbers absprayen.
Vom Wasserstrahl.
Und, äh, danach steh ich auf und putz ab mit, äh,
mit Klopapier.
Klopapier.
Das Social Distancing Dashboarder.
Das können wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Die besitzen abputzen alle.
Das sind Kacken.
Genauso wie die, wie die Noobs auf Twitter
am Start gewesen sind wieder.
Ähm, so, ich muss mal kurz den Chat schauen.
Ähm, es gab ja hier eben
ein paar Questions.
Moin, Desinator.
Äh, irgendjemand hat was mit VPN gefragt gerade.
Ich seh's nicht.
Ah, hier.
Der Umut hat gefragt.
Ich muss für ein paar Leute VPNs in das Büro einrichten.
Was empfiehlst du da?
Kommt drauf an, mit was für einer Hardware.
Auf was soll das Ganze laufen?
Habt ihr da schon Hardware für?
Wollt ihr da eigene Hardware für installieren?
Was habt ihr für Clients?
Das ist nicht so pauschal einfach zu beantworten.
Ihr habt Happipo.
Was, was ist Happipo?
Kann man danach suchen?
Ist das safe?
Happi?
Happipo?
DM, ja, das scheint safe zu sein.
What?
Was ist Happipo, Alter?
Haha.
Das ist ja cool.
Das füllst du mit warmem Wasser auf.
Und dann sprayst du dir den Bobbus ab.
Das ist ja nice, was es nicht alles gibt.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal auf YouTube angucken.
Happipo.
Intim mit Nico.
Äh.
Happipo.
Okay.
Okay, Moment, Leute.
Happipo.
Da passt, irgendwie passt die Musik gerade wunderbar zu dem Video.
Warte mal.
Happipo.
Gestatten?
Po.
Ja, das hier ist ein echter Happipo.
Aber früher war es ihm ziemlich dreckig.
Die Stimmung in seiner Stadt war gereizt.
Das ist ein Schuss.
Klopapier und Poes gerieten ständig aneinander.
Oh.
Und den Preis dafür zahlten die armen Bäume.
Po wollte etwas Besseres.
Er zog aus, um eine Lösung zu finden.
Er suchte auf der ganzen Welt.
Das tut ja weh.
Wasser mahlt alle Körperteile sauber.
Und genauso toll den Po.
Poris.
Wie bekommt man sowas stressfrei nach Hause?
Ganz einfach.
Mit Happipo.
Der Podusche.
Sexy.
Unkompliziert.
Was mich bei Happipo übelst verwirrt ist, Happipo hat den Bobbes oben auf dem Kopf.
Aber die Beine hat er unten.
Das heißt, es ist die Frage, hat er vielleicht zwei Poes?
Hat er oben den großen Po und hier unten nochmal einen?
Weil ansonsten würde er ja quasi aus dem Kopf scheißen.
Happipo.
Der Podusche.
Sexy.
Unkompliziert.
Ohne unnötigen Schnick-Schnack.
Ohne unnötigen Schnick-Schnack passt sie in jede Hand.
Und hat mächtig Dampf im Strahl.
Oh nein.
Und mit so einem Wasserstrahl darf ich das alles gleich machen?
seven times.
Sexy.
Sexy-Unkompliziert.
Ohne unnötigen Schnick-Schnack.
Aber was, was, was?
Leider in der Höhe ist der Po.
Sexy.
Ohne unnötigen Schnick-Schnack.
Was?
Mächtig Dampf im Strahl.
Alter, wenn er nicht mit so einem Wasserstrahl von hinten anschießt, der bis zum Mars geht, ich glaube, da willst du nicht im Weg sitzen.
So wird jeder Po unwiderstehlich sauber.
Happy Po ist super sanft zur Po-Haut und braucht viel weniger Papier.
So lässt sich jeder Po mit seinem Klopapier versöhnen.
Das braucht man nur noch zum Abtrocknen.
Mutter Natur kann sich erholen.
Comfy Klo.
Ein Happy End für alle, wenn es wirklich sanft und sauber werden soll.
Ich finde, das ist cool zu sehen, was es alles gibt.
Also, das heißt, hätte ich nicht hier mein Klo mit eingebautem, dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch Happy Po kaufen.
Happy Po. Happy Po klingt echt gut.
So, hat derjenige geantwortet mit...
VPN.
Eigene Hardware, macOS und Windows.
Eigene Hardware.
Also, steht da im Endeffekt ein Raspberry Pi rum, oder?
Ja, dann probier mal WireGuard.
WireGuard ist einfach aufzusetzen und die Clients sind auch ganz gut.
Ich hätte gesagt, wenn du das jetzt mit einem vorhandenen Cisco-Switch oder irgendwie Gedöns machen willst, was...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Switche das überhaupt können.
Dann wäre es wahrscheinlich IPsec geworden.
Aber nachdem du frei...
Wahl hast drumherum, dann würde ich es mit WireGuard probieren.
WireGuard ist einfach zu installieren.
Happy Po war sogar in der Höhle der Löwen.
Okay, das gucke ich nicht.
So.
Ich wollte euch mal was Cooles zeigen.
Guck mal, was ich gefunden habe hier.
Für Linux-Kommandozeile.
Ein Corona-Tracker für die Kommandozeile.
Das ist doch nice, oder?
Wow.
Okay.
Das unterstützt wohl irgendwie keine Farmen.
Da.
Guck, der Niger hat einen.
Und wir haben...
Wir haben 21.854.
Was sagt denn da World Info Corona dazu?
Alter Leute, das ist ein Land.
Ich kann auch nichts dafür, dass das Land so heißt.
Oh, guck mal, das ist ziemlich aktuell.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, wo der die Daten herzieht.
Man kann das bestimmt auch sortieren.
Nach Land oder so.
Ah, hier, guck.
US.
Das ist hier für Kokona Land.
Die Jungfrauinsel.
So, gibt es auch DE?
Ah, Germany hat nur eins zusammen.
Moment.
Warum ist Confirmed für die einzelnen Länder
niedriger
als in der Gesamtübersicht?
Ne.
Ach so.
Ah, ich brauche die Live-Übersicht.
Ich brauche die Live-Übersicht.
Die, die ist, guck mal, wenn wir jetzt hier Grab
Germany machen,
dann sind wir aktuell.
Guck mal, man sieht sogar, ob das,
man sieht sogar den Rank.
Wird schon einer in dem Leben da nur Informatik ganz kürzlich anbieten, oder?
Kann man, wie kriege ich denn das jetzt
gescheit geprintet? So, hier.
Huge.
Gehen wir mal Head.
Äh, ne, minus N ist es. Minus N.
Fünf.
Oder nicht?
Was, Head fünf? Einfach nur fünf?
Alter, ich bin zu doof.
Ich bin zu dumm, ne?
Die einfachsten Linux-Kommando-Zeilen-Tools
zu verwenden. Seht ihr?
Leute, Wahnsinn, oder?
Aber wir können ja nachgucken.
Wieso? Ich habe es doch richtig gemacht.
Ich habe es doch richtig gemacht.
Minus N. Fünf.
Warum geht das nicht?
Von hinten geht es.
Aber von vorne geht es nicht.
Warum ist das so?
Na gut, es ist ganz einfach.
Wir müssen einfach noch...
Wir müssen einfach noch ein bisschen steigen.
In den Corona-Zahlen.
Dann, ähm...
Dann geht es bei uns auch.
Ah, jetzt mit 20 funktioniert es.
Okay, was auch immer.
Also, bei uns sind
neun Leute gestorben.
Kann Watch eigentlich Colors?
Watch kann Colors?
Oh, jetzt wird es aber advanced hier.
Guck mal, jetzt machen wir nämlich einfach so.
Und dann aktualisierst du das immer.
Ist das nicht einfach so?
Ja.
Oh, nice.
Oh, ja.
Bam.
So, und dann müssen wir Curl noch Minus N,
dass das Quiet ist, machen.
Ne, Minus Q, Minus S.
Was ist Quiet bei Curl?
WTF? Ich kann mir...
Warum kann ich mir Basic Linux Kommandozeilen
Zeug nicht merken, ne?
Curl war Quiet.
Was war Quiet?
Quiet.
Silent, was Minus S? Minus S.
Warum?
Warum ist dieser Scheiß
in jedem Kommandozeilen-Programm anders?
Ha?
Minus klein S.
Warum müssen die überall...
Mal ist es Minus N,
mal ist es Minus Q, mal ist es Minus S.
Die wehren sich nicht ein.
Ich guckte mal.
So.
Und jetzt aktualisiert sich das alle zwei Sekunden
und da habe ich meinen Corona...
meinen K-K-Corona-Tracker
im Terminal.
Das ist doch pock, oder?
Max, ich hätte auch eine Frage zum Thema
Side-to-Side VPN.
Mit Zertifikatsbasierter Authentifizierung.
Da habe ich meine Abschlussarbeit drüber gemacht.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich mich da heute
mit noch auskenne.
So, was hat denn hier der...
Ist das der...
Ne, das ist ein anderer, oder?
Das ist nicht der mit dem Bahn-Mining-Talk.
Oder ist das der mit dem Bahn-Mining-Talk?
Oder ist der Name?
Oder ist der Name einfach nur ähnlich?
Ne, Griesel heißt der.
Und das ist auch ein anderer.
Das ist ein anderer.
Das ist ein Kreisel.
Moin, After Maths F4.
Quick Maths.
Dort steht eine Linungskiste, die du managst.
Ja, dann Wireguard.
Dann würde ich Wireguard nehmen.
Was ist heute der Plan?
Ich habe keinen Plan.
Also, das ist wie immer.
Ich habe gedacht, ich mache einfach mal den Stream an.
Erstens, weil ich sonst nichts zu tun habe gerade.
Außerdem, weil ich den ganzen Tag
rumgebastelt habe am Rechner und keinen Bock habe,
irgendwie noch weiter zu basteln, habe ich mir gedacht,
ey,
weißt du was, mach einfach mal den Stream an
und guck, was so geht.
Wir werden nachher noch mal gucken,
ob es noch ein paar Großhändler gibt,
die noch Klopapier verkaufen,
weil auf Twitter sind ja mal wieder alle eskaliert.
Also nicht alle, das stimmt ja nicht.
Ich übertreibe ja manchmal.
Es sind nicht alle eskaliert.
Ein paar Leute sind eskaliert,
weil ich, das ist übrigens, was ist denn das?
Optimiert für 800x600 und Internet Explorer oder
was ist mit Twitter los?
Ich habe ja auf Twitter gepostet,
dass ich Klopapier bestellt habe,
nämlich 96 Rollen Klopapier.
Und da kamen öfters mal so Antworten in die Richtung wie,
du dummer Spast.
Und solche Sachen.
Ich hätte gar nicht damit gedacht, ehrlich gesagt,
dass dieser Post, also das da, dass dieser Post,
so viele Leute triggern könnte,
hätte ich nicht vermutet, ja.
Man muss sich nämlich mal überlegen,
was sind denn die Alternativen dazu?
Also gehen wir mal von aus.
Oh, den Chat sieht man nicht mehr im Stream.
Der Cute Chat ist weg.
Der ist noch vom Playstation Event weg.
Jetzt ist der Cute Chat wieder da.
Äh, spread the beast.
Neun Monate, dankeschön.
Huge, sub.
Ups, falscher Knopf.
Klops Russia.
Zwei Monate, auch dankeschön.
Ich hoffe, ich hab nix übersehen.
GD Kono, drei Monate abonniert.
Dankeschön, huge, sub.
Der High Noob ist auch wieder am Start.
Weitig hatte ich schon, aber trotzdem.
Huge, sub.
Alles übersehen, ne.
So.
Ähm, und was ich interessant fand,
dass sich, dass da einige,
es waren ja nicht so viele, ja,
aber dass da einige drüber getriggert waren.
Und wenn man sich mal überlegt,
was sind denn die Alternativen?
Ich bin der Meinung,
wir wären besser dran,
würden alle Leute einfach online
ihr Klopapier bestellen.
Weil dann könnten die Leute,
die keine Möglichkeit haben,
oder wirklich mal auf die Schnelle was brauchen,
einfach in den Supermarkt gehen und was holen.
Und alles würde deutlich geplanter
und koordinierter laufen,
wenn du im Vorfeld weißt,
wer wie viel wohin bestellt hat.
Also, ich bin der Meinung,
ich mach das richtig.
Und wenn man sich mal überlegt,
was ist die Alternative?
Also, man braucht aktuell, würde ich mal sagen,
schon drei bis vier Wochen Vorrat.
Man weiß ja nie, vielleicht wird man ja krank.
Und wenn man krank ist
und das Ganze auch schon mal zwei, drei, vier Wochen dauern kann,
bis man wieder gesund ist
und man am besten dann nicht rausgehen sollte
in den Supermarkt,
dann braucht man ein bisschen Vorrat.
Natürlich sind 96 Rollen ein bisschen viel.
Ähm,
wie kann ich dich mit Prime abonnieren,
da ich Prime habe, es mir aber nicht angezeigt wird?
Ganz normal auf dem gleichen Button
wie alles andere auch.
Aber vielleicht hast du ja,
Twitch und Amazon nicht verknüpft.
Ich hätte ja auch
kleinere Menge bestellt,
anstatt 96 Rollen, ja.
Also, ich hätte mich auch mit der Hälfte zufrieden gegeben.
Aber ich habe bei einem Großhändler bestellt
für so einen Bürobedarfladen
und der hat halt nur das kleinste,
das war halt 96 Rollen.
So, und was ist die Alternative aktuell?
Supermärkte geben teilweise
nur noch einen Pack pro Person raus.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt mal
für den Fall der Fälle,
dass man krank wird,
einen Vorrat von drei, vier Wochen braucht,
hast du absolut keine Chance,
irgendwas zu bekommen.
Ähm, und die Alternative ist einfach,
jetzt sich für eine Woche lang
jeden Tag morgens
in die Menge zu stellen
und jeweils
eine Packung Klopapier abzugreifen.
Warum soll ich denn mich gerade jetzt
in die Menge der Leute stellen
im Supermarkt?
Also sprich, wenn du jetzt noch kein Corona hast,
danach hast du es auf jeden Fall.
SilentPain hat abonniert, neun Monate.
Huge Sub.
So, also ich hab ungefähr,
also ich hab mal ausgerechnet,
so im normalen Verbrauch
brauchen wir ungefähr,
mit zwei Personen,
brauchen wir so ungefähr eins,
eine Rolle am Tag.
Ungefähr.
Und jetzt, wo ich halt auch Homeoffice hab
und den ganzen Tag daheim bin,
im Endeffekt würde ich mal sagen,
eineinhalb Rollen oder sowas.
Aber ich bin ja auch ein Kneuler
und kein Falter.
Was ist mit euch los?
Was ist mit euch?
Prink abonniert Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Wenn das Greta hört, ja,
da hab ich schon Angst vor.
Ähm, ja, so ist das halt, ne.
So ist halt meine,
wie nennt man es,
wie soll man es nennen?
Kack-Gewohnheiten.
Ich falte nicht, ich knäule.
Und dann kommt da halt sowas raus
und wir sind zwei Personen,
das heißt, wir brauchen ungefähr
eine Rolle am Tag.
Ähm, natürlich ist da nicht,
da ist nicht nur Kacken dabei,
da ist auch Zeug abputzen
und sonst was dabei.
Also, das heißt, das Ganze reicht mit 96 Rollen,
reichen für zwei Personen dann irgendwie so,
ich hab jetzt mal mit eineinhalb Rollen gerechnet,
mit eineinhalb Rollen so zwei,
zwei, drei Monate vielleicht.
Äh, Auskennfuchs, man braucht da theoretisch
auch kein Papier mehr.
Aber ich putz trotzdem nochmal ab danach.
Aber nicht mit so viel wie sonst.
Sibaro, neun Monate,
der Cute-Mod ist am Start.
Ja, ja, ja.
Da ist er, danke schön für den Sub.
Switchst du zwischen Linux und Windows herum?
Ja.
Ach, wie?
Äh, mit Control Alt,
ne, mit,
mit Steuerung Windows links und rechts.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das nicht,
was du wissen wolltest,
sondern das ist VMware Workstation.
VMware Workstation.
Ja, guck da, VMware Workstation.
Und hier haben wir unsere,
unser aktuelles Corona Update.
New Cases.
Es geht hoch, Leute.
Die Chinesen haben angeblich keine neuen Corona-Fälle.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel an der Informationspolitik.
Aus China.
Blutet da nicht der Hintern, wenn man mit so viel Klopapier rumschrubbt?
Übung macht den Meister.
Ich muss euch ja auch mal sagen, ne, ich bin ja selbst ein bisschen schockiert über die
Leute.
Wie bescheuert die meisten sind, ne.
Ich war, ich hab's doch, ich hab's, ich hab's ja hier auf Twitter gepostet.
Ich war, ich bin zum Rewe gegangen, ne.
Ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's,
ich hab's doch, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's ja hier auf Twitter
gepostet.
Ich war, ich bin zum Rewe gelaufen, am Main lang.
Ähm, ich bin zum Rewe gelaufen am Main lang.
Und, was das erste, was ich gesehen hab, ist, als ich am Main runtergekommen bin.
Und eine Gruppe vorne kam.
keine Ahnung, 15, 20 Leuten
haben auf einer riesen Decke gepicknickt
am Main, so schön in der Sonne,
oh ja, YOLO, Corona, was juckt's mich,
vollkommen egal, haben sie sich
gedacht und
das ist einfach, also was man daran
wieder sieht ist,
wenn du dich darauf verlassen musst,
dass andere
Leute das Richtige machen,
dann bist du komplett verlassen, ja,
dann hast du komplett gelitten
und
das Problem
an der Sache ist jetzt ja nur,
dass man
normalerweise ja da irgendwie
selbst verantwortlich ist, aber in dem Fall
liegt's ja
gar nicht mal an einem selber
so sehr, wenn man
den Scheiß kriegt, ja,
und danach
war das Problem,
ich bin weitergelaufen, bin ich auf dem Rückweg,
als ich vom Rewe zurückgekommen bin,
also Lidl und Rewe ist da quasi
so auf einer Ecke,
und
als ich zurückgekommen bin, kam mir
ein Familienausflug entgegen,
drei Familien,
also drei Paare, mit
Kinderwagen, die haben quasi die, da ist so eine
Brücke über den Main, haben gerade den Kinderwagen
die Treppe hochgetragen
und das waren 15 Leute oder so,
auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, drei Familien,
jeder irgendwie gefühlt, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, drei, vier Kinder
und ach, keine Ahnung, es war viel, es war voll,
ja, und
da hab ich mir auch gedacht,
wie bescheuert,
ähm, wie bescheuert
kann man eigentlich sein,
die Leute gehen danach zu Opa und
Oma wahrscheinlich, zum Abendessen
und, äh,
denken sich nichts bei, und
danach beschweren sie sich noch, warum
sie keiner davor beschützt hätte, weil
Oma und Opa an Corona verreckt
ist. Das sind Leute, die kommen
nie im Leben auf die Idee, dass sie selber
dran schuld sind. Kennt ihr so Leute, die
permanent am Rumheulen sind,
dass, ähm, die Welt
gemeint zu ihnen ist,
so nach dem Motto, hier wär ich
irgendwie nicht richtig behandelt und hier haben sie mich
wieder schon verarscht und, und
ich hab ja auch nur ne Fünf gekriegt, weil mich der
Lehrer nicht mag und hier bin ich eigentlich auch
immer nur verarscht worden, dass dann
irgendwie mal einer von den Leuten
auf die Idee kommen würde,
dass das mit an ihnen liegt,
ich mein, man kann immer Pech haben, klar,
du kannst auch komplett, du kannst auch
komplett unverschuldet, äh, über den Haufen
gefahren werden, ja, also, das
liegt nicht immer nur an dir, aber wenn du
permanent,
immer nur
Scheiße baust
und, ähm, der Meinung ist,
die Welt hat sich gegen dich verschworen
und dir nie was Gutes passiert, dann sollte
man sich vielleicht mal überlegen, ob man nicht da selbst
mit dran schuld ist.
Und, ähm, das sind
genau die gleichen Leute, machen Familienausflug
mit drei Paaren, gehen danach zu
Opa und Oma, stecken Opa
und Oma mit Corona an,
Opa und Oma stirbt da dran
und danach wird rumgeheult,
warum hat der Staat nix gemacht, warum
hat die Polizei nix gemacht, warum hat das Land
nix gemacht, warum hat das Krankenhaus nix
gemacht, warum ist unser Sozialsystem,
warum ist unsere Krankenversicherung so
schlecht, warum ist alles so schlecht und wir haben
doch nix gemacht. So.
Immer der gleiche Scheiß, ey, die Leute sind so
unglaublich bescheuert,
ähm, das
gibt's nicht, ja,
und
es geht ja gar nicht so sehr darum, dass man die ganze
Sache komplett verhindern könnte,
das heißt, das weiß ich mir auch, wo ich mich auch schon
von Anfang an frage, ähm,
mit, mit was sagen, komm, es geht ja gar nicht
darum, dass das, dass das komplett verhindert
wird, dass man sich ansteckt, das heißt,
es gibt durchaus Kombinationen,
das hat grad einer im Chat geschrieben,
äh, die Mutter arbeitet beim Rewe und so, ja, klar,
äh, die Chance, dass du's kriegst, früher oder
später, sind relativ hoch und bei dir wahrscheinlich eher,
eher früher,
aber insgesamt bringt das
einiges. Es gibt, es, ich
hab eben grad ne Grafik gesehen,
äh, zu Südkorea,
ich muss grad mal gucken, ob ich die finde,
ne Grafik zu Südkorea,
ähm, Japan
und den restlichen
Ländern, wo man halt
sieht, wo die Bevölkerung diszipliniert
ist
und
wo nicht, hier, warte mal,
ich hab's gefunden, gefunden, Leute,
hier, guckt euch
das mal an, so,
guckt euch das mal an,
Japan, Südkorea,
grad die Japaner sind ja
ultra diszipliniert, was solche Sachen angeht,
wenn in Japan einer sagt, mach's ne nicht,
dann machst du's auch nicht,
das ist nicht so, wie
bei uns, wenn da, wenn da die Polizei sagt,
ähm, äh,
Polizei sagt, mach's ne nicht, dann sagt
bei uns die Leute erstmal, alter, lull, Polizei,
fick dich, alte,
Polizei, ey, ich, ne,
das ist,
dann macht das halt keiner, ja,
äh, in Japan ist das anders,
ähm,
in Japan, wenn da einer sagt, mach's ne nicht,
dann mach's ne nicht und in Japan ist es
wahrscheinlich schon, ähm,
überhaupt
beleidigend, wenn du es überhaupt
sagen musst, dass du nicht selbst allein auf die Idee gekommen bist,
ja, so, also Japan
überhaupt kein Ding, Südkorea
hat da am Anfang,
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wir hatten letztens hier einen
aus Südkorea im Stream,
ähm, da waren wir hier so irgendwie,
na, so, so, da waren wir ungefähr
auf der Höhe, äh, Südkorea
und Deutschland und da hat man's halt
gesehen, in Südkorea funktioniert der Scheiß,
ja, du musst nicht ins Internetcafé,
du musst nicht in, äh,
äh, irgendwelche anderen Dinger, was halt
die Südkoreaner so gerne machen oder
Karaoke-Kram, was weiß ich, ähm,
äh, die kriegen das ja auch gemacht.
Was ich übrigens auch eine Sache,
die mir nicht ganz einleuchtet ist,
ich mein, ja,
die, äh,
der normale Mundschutz,
der normale
Mundschutz, der bringt, äh,
erstmal nix. Okay, dann ist
natürlich die nächste Frage, die ich mir stelle, es gibt,
also es gibt ja Mundschutz, der was bringt,
zumindest mehr als dieser normale Mundschutz,
und wo der normale Mundschutz
auch schon was bringt, äh, ich kann den Link auch
in Chat posten, ja, und wo der
normale, wo der normal, hups, äh,
ich kann grad irgendwie nicht den,
ah, jetzt,
wo der normale Mundschutz was bringt, ist auch,
dass man die anderen Leute nicht ansteckt. So,
und wisst ihr, was ich mich frage? Warum gibt
es nicht am Eingang von jedem
Supermarkt, ich mein, der Supermarkt ist das
Ding, wo aktuell alle noch hingehen
und rein müssen, warum gibt's dann nicht
einfach, ähm, entweder die
Regel, nur mit, nur mit Maske rein,
und das würde allerdings nur funktionieren,
wenn es auch Masken
gäbe für die Leute, ja,
ähm, weil dann hast
du zumindest die Gefahr ein bisschen
geringer, dass du andere Leute ansteckst,
wenn du so ein Ding
auffasst.
Ich hab das Gefühl, wir machen das
ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ähm,
gibt halt halt,
ey, bei uns im Supermarkt, bei uns im EDK
steht so ein Security-Dude rum.
Ja, ja, ihr könnt keine bestellen,
das ist klar, ähm, ich sag ja auch nicht,
Einzelhandel oder generell die Supermärkte sich
darum kümmern müssten, das ist so eine Sache, wo ich
tatsächlich in dem Fall mal, ähm,
das jeweilige Land oder, oder generell
auch, auch unsere Regierung und Deutschland
in der Pflicht sehen würde, dass man sowas
eben hat. Ich mein, wir haben, wir haben
ja für alles irgendwelche Vorräte, aber daran
anscheinend nicht.
Ähm, der, der Shop, wo ich
mein Klopapier bestellt hab, also,
da, wo sie mich hier geflammt haben,
der hat ja auch geschrieben, dass
es sein kann, dass die Bestellung
ein bisschen später kommt, weil,
sie will so zuerst Krankenhäuser beliefern.
Ja, da, da bin ich der Letzte, der da was dagegen sagt.
Ja gut,
ich hab eh kein Problem, ich hab ja hier meine,
ich hab ja hier meine Maske.
Also, wenn ich wirklich mal in irgendwie
ein total verseuchtes Gebiet muss,
dann
zieh ich mir
einfach dieses Ding hier auf.
Wo hab ich's?
Hier. Wenn ich mal in wirklich
total verseuchtes Ding muss, dann zieh ich mir das Ding
hier auf und dann ist vorbei. Da
hat der Virus keine Chance.
Da mach ich mal ein Metro-Cosplay.
Bei uns im Lidl auch nur, ja,
äh, ich hab's gesehen, bei uns im Edeka
ist auch so, da haben sie durch einen halben Laden
solche Abstandsstreifen jetzt hingemacht.
Masken haben fast alle
Ausatemventile, die ungefiltert sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob so ein normaler Mundschutz,
so ein normaler OP-Mundschutz, der hat
bestimmt keine Ausatemventile.
Ähm, deswegen hilft's ja auch
was dagegen, dass man andere Leute ansteckt.
Bei der Geschichte könnte es tatsächlich
sein, dass der Ausatemventile
hat, nicht andere Leute ansteckt. Allerdings,
ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist.
Das Ding zieh ich mir ja auch nur an,
wenn ich mich selber nicht anstecken will.
Was sind das für Filter? Das sind P3R,
das ist gegen Virus,
äh, gegen Viren und, und
so, da gibt's so eine Tabelle, Tabelle
gegen was das hilft, haben wir uns letztens im Stream angeguckt.
Wen juckt das Ausatmen?
Das Ausatmen ist ganz entscheidend, weil
zumindest bei dem Fall, wenn man in den
Supermarkt geht und, äh, nicht viele andere
Leute anstecken will. Weil
das Problem ist ja, du weißt's ja oftmals
gar nicht, ob du's hast. Du bist
ja schon lange ansteckend, bevor du's merkst,
naja, gut, aber
jetzt genug zu dem Zeug. Aber man sieht hier
mit ein bisschen Disziplin, funktioniert
das Ganze ganz gut. Achso,
ja, das hier, das Ding zieh ich an, dass ich
mich nicht anstecke, ganz klar.
Ich hatte's
bis jetzt noch nicht an. Ich hab's mir
ja auch, wie gesagt, nur gekauft,
nicht für Corona oder so,
ich hab's mir ja davor schon gekauft, für Schimmel
und Zeug, wo man Kram sauber machen muss.
Aber jetzt ist es halt ganz praktisch, dass ich
das Teil habe. Wenn ich wirklich mal irgendwo
hin muss, wo die totale Seuche ist, dann zieh ich das
Ding an. Ah, vorbei.
Ähm, aber was man, finde ich, hier ganz
gut sieht, ist, mit ein bisschen Disziplin
funktioniert das.
Ja, die Amis
haben komplett gelitten.
Die haben ja aktuell eher so
die Sorgen, wo krieg ich noch schnell
Waffen her? Ich hab zu wenig Waffen,
ich brauch mehr Waffen, also, scheiß
auf Corona, Hauptsache noch mal eine MP5 gekauft.
Max spiegelt sich im
XR-Fly-Film, ja.
Ähm,
da ist mal noch eine MP5 gekauft, wobei ich weiß,
gar nicht, ob eine MP5 da jetzt
im Trend ist. Was kaufen sich denn die Amis aktuell
so? Weiß nicht, weiß nicht.
M4? Vielleicht ein M4
oder so?
AR-15? Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß
nicht, was die sich so kaufen. Aber zumindest
AR-15, ja, glaub ich auch.
AR-15 ist doch eine M4, oder?
Ein RPG! Ja,
man kann ja schon mal für den
Ernstfall aufrüsten.
So, und die haben, die haben grad
richtig gelitten, weil die haben ja irgendwie
aktuell auf Ferien.
Also, ne, die in den USA
gehabt haben, die haben ja irgendwie gerade, was ist denn das?
Osterferien oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und da geht's jetzt halt
richtig hoch. Da geht's halt voll ab
gerade. Ich betone nochmal,
dummer Spast.
Ich muss immer lachen, wenn ich
die Comments lese teilweise, ey.
Ich find's geil. Die Leute waren so
ultra getriggert, ne.
Dummer Spast hatten wir hier, da hatten wir noch
hier Leute, die sich drüber aufgeregt haben.
So dumm, das reicht doch.
Bla, warum so viel?
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Oh, den kenn ich übrigens.
Den kenn ich übrigens, L hier.
Das fällt mir gerade ein.
Ähm.
Ja, teilweise
voll aufgeregt, ne.
Aber war das halt das Kleinste, was es gibt.
So, okay, was zum Geil war
das? Das hat mir vorhin irgendjemand geschickt.
Was ist das? Social Distancing
Dashboard. Äh, ich muss mal kurz
schauen, hab ich irgendwelche
Subscriber übersehen vielleicht?
Das wäre ja nicht auszudenken.
Ne, sieht nicht so aus.
Zuletzt hatten wir den Sibaro.
Was für eine grafische Oberfläche
nutzt du unter deinem Linux i3 WM?
Also Leute, wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen
habt, sei es zur Technik, zu
äh, Linux, äh,
Computerkrams, Technik allgemein,
Heimautomatisierung, sonst was, haut's einfach raus.
Ich hab heute nichts Spezielles vor im Stream.
Ja. Äh, was hältst
du vom
Sarg-Gesetz
wie die letzten Tage das Thema bei den
meisten Finanzier... Was?
Äh, Flo619, ne, ich hab bestellt.
Ich hab das Ding erst mal nur Klopapier-Stream genannt
und ich wollte mal gucken, ob es nicht vielleicht...
Ich hatte nämlich vorhin die, die übelste
Big-Brain-Idee. Ich hab, ich hab
mir gedacht, gibt es nicht vielleicht Österreich
aus Klopapier?
Also nicht Österreich...
Nicht Österreich aus Klopapier.
Gibt es nicht vielleicht Klopapier aus Österreich bestellen?
Kann man das machen? Vielleicht haben die ja mehr.
Was brauchst du, um eine Lampen alles
zu steuern? Wenn du deine Lampen steuern
willst, dann ist die beste Variante...
Wir reden jetzt mal hier von Ein- und Ausschalten.
Dann ist die beste Sache, die du dir gerne...
kaufen kannst, ein Shelly.
Hat mit Cloud nichts zu tun. Die Dinger
funktionieren komplett offline, wenn man
das will. Ähm,
und zwar, die... What the fuck, den da.
Ein Shelly 1 kaufst du dir.
Das ist ein Relay.
Das kannst du in die...
unter den Schalter, unter den Licht...
unter den Lichtschalter machen.
Das heißt,
du kannst dein Licht nach wie vor
mit dem Schalter ein- und ausschalten, allerdings
auch per WLAN.
Das ist das Beste.
Was hältst du von VBA?
Nix. Also von
Visual Basic bin ich als ich kein großer Fan.
Ich glaube,
VBA ist halt das
Einzige, wo man Office-Krams
automatisieren kann.
Wie groß war nochmal der NAS
und wie viel Speicher ist aktuell noch frei?
Also, ich hab ja vorher...
hatte ich ja meine 4HE-Kiste.
Also, sprich,
das Ding hatte ich ja vorher.
Hier oben, die Kiste.
Da waren...
3x10TB drin.
Und jetzt hab ich nur noch eine Kiste,
weil das komplett oversized war.
Und jetzt hab ich nur noch eine Kiste.
Da ist eine 12TB-Platte drin
und eine 12TB-Platte
Backup, wo nächtlich
einmal gesynct wird.
Und das meiste, ich glaub, 2TB sind insgesamt
belegt mit allem, was drauf ist.
Also, es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Hat Schläger noch auf?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, Sibaro, ne?
Da ist die...
Da fließt die Kohle.
Leider hab ich so das Gefühl,
oder ich könnte mir vorstellen,
also Sibaro hat grad geschrieben,
was ich ganz interessant finde,
sonst ist nie Geld im Staat oder der EU da,
aber wenn es im Notfall gibt,
kann man eben 750 Milliarden locker machen.
Mich würde es ja sehr interessieren,
ob von diesen 750 Milliarden
auch woanders was ankommt,
als bei riesengroß Unternehmen.
Also, sprich,
kommt von den 750 Milliarden auch was an,
bei kleineren, bei mittelständischen
und vielleicht auch bei den ein oder anderen Leuten,
die es wirklich nötig haben.
Moin, bekommst du Harz?
Ne, ich geh ganz normal arbeiten.
Ich bin ein bisschen hinten dran mit dem Chat.
Kannst du eventuell was von deinem OSM-Projekt zeigen?
Soll ich?
Wollt ihr das sehen?
Also, ich kann es ja nochmal sagen,
ich bin ja grad dabei mit nem...
Da muss ich aber die Uhr ausblenden.
Ich bin ja grad dabei mit meinem...
mit nem Kollege.
Also, mit dem verstehe ich mich.
Gut, deswegen passt das.
Das kann man nur...
Kann man...
So Projekte kann man nur machen mit Leuten,
wo man sich gut versteht.
Wir sind ja grad dabei, ein...
ja, ein Tool zu programmieren
für...
Wie heißt denn sowas so?
Für Betriebe, die quasi Installateure haben, ja?
Also, sprich, für nen...
Klempner oder für nen Heizungsbaumensch oder so,
wo die ihre Termine planen können.
Sprich, da kannst du eintragen,
welche Kunden haben Wartungsverträge
und da kannst du sagen,
okay, jetzt stehen mal wieder
bei den Kunden mit Wartungsverträgen
steht jetzt mal demnächst wieder nen Besuch an,
Heizungswartung
und, ähm, das errechnet dir dann optimale Ru...
oder nahezu optimale Routen.
Optimale Routen an sich gibt's ja nicht.
Ähm, nahezu optimale Routen,
wie man die Leute abfahren kann.
Ich kann euch was von zeigen, wenn ihr wollt, ja?
Aktuell basiert das Ganze...
Aber ich kann nicht...
Ich kann ja was...
Ich muss aber die Uhrl ausblenden.
Ja, oh Mut, kann ich aber.
Nun sagt mir jetzt nix.
Äh, hey Max, hast du mal was,
mit ONFIF-Cams gemacht?
Ähm, möchte gerne den ONFIF-Stream
einer China-Cam aufzeichnen.
Ja, und zwar, was ich dazu sagen kann,
äh, ONFIF ist, äh, kein Streaming-Protokoll.
ONFIF ist...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das überhaupt ONFIF ausspricht.
Das ist nen, nen Standard über XML,
wo man, äh, Daten zu der Kamera abfragen kann.
Die Streams gehen nicht über ONFIF,
die Streams gehen ganz normal
über RTSP oder andere Geschichten.
Also für die Streams brauchst du kein ONFIF,
du brauchst nur die Stream-Adresse.
Die musst du rauskriegen.
Das hat mit...
Das andere ist nur ein reines Info-Ding.
Äh, welche Shell benutzt du?
Das ist ZSH, äh, in dem GNOME-Terminal
und aber kein, kein Riesen-Plugin-Gedöns.
Ich muss gerade den Chat ein bisschen aufholen, Leute.
Ich bin, ich bin nicht schnell genug.
Ja, Daddy Khan, wir wünschen dir alle, alle viel Glück.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was ein PIC-Simulator ist,
aber du machst das schon.
Wie hast du deine Heizung automatisiert?
Sagt mal, Leute, hatte ich nicht ein Tool-Programm,
was die ganzen, was die ganzen Stream-Fragen aufzeichnet?
Ich hatte doch da mal was gebastelt hier.
Ich hatte doch mal ein Tool programmiert,
was die ganzen Stream-Fragen aufzeichnet,
dass ich nichts übersehe.
Twitch-Chat.
Ist es doch.
Warum habe ich denn das nicht mehr an?
Warum habe ich, warum habe ich denn das nicht mehr laufen?
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Das, weil, brauche ich jetzt, könnte ich jetzt nämlich gerade gebrauchen.
Ja, ja.
Äh, Neradon Stufe 1, acht Monate lang, schön.
Fuck.
Wow.
Java.
Monkeys.
Was ist das?
Wow.
Wenn man Java braucht, um eine .NET IDE aufzumachen,
da ist schon irgendwas verkehrt, äh.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Okay.
Ähm.
Wo habe ich denn hier meinen,
meinen Twitch-Chat?
Twitch-Chat.
Okay.
Ist das das?
Twitch-Chat.
Private Message.
Das ist das?
Okay, starten wir mal.
Äh.
Okay, ich beantworte noch mal schnell alle anderen Fragen und dann.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Oh.
Kann man mit einem neuen .NET Framework nicht ein altes .NET Programm starten?
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn?
Hm.
Da muss ich gleich mal gucken.
Dein Friseur hat Insolvenz angemeldet.
Feels Batman.
Neonimus Stufe 1, dankeschön.
Six heads up.
Sag mal, ich suche nach einer Möglichkeit über OSM.
Leaflet 3D Objekte.
Da kenne ich nichts zu.
Okay, so.
Ähm.
Warum kann man das nicht starten?
Kann man das Projekt vielleicht einfach upgraden?
Das Problem hatte ich noch nie.
Target Framework.
Ah, man muss dort nicht Standard targeten, dann geht das wahrscheinlich, ne?
Wow.
Und jetzt?
Uh.
What the fuck?
Höh.
Was?
Was geht ab?
Warum geht mein Zeug nicht mehr?
What?
Warum geht mein Shit nicht mehr?
Wow.
Was ist das?
Warum ist das kaputt?
Warum geht mein, warum geht mein Frage-Log-Tool nicht mehr?
Moment.
Das ist nicht das Frage-Log-Tool, Leute.
Das ist gar nicht das Frage-Log-Tool.
Das Frage-Log-Tool war viel, war viel länger?
Da war eine ganze ASP.NET Anwendung drumherum.
Warte mal, das ist gar nicht, das ist gar nicht das richtige.
Was?
eine Programme mal ordentlich nennen würde.
Web-Application
2.
Web-Dings.
Okay, von wann
ist denn das hier? Juni.
Okay, wir fangen jetzt mal von hinten an. Web-Application
2. Huge Benennung. True.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Das ist eine...
Das ist die Blazer. Die Blazer-To-Do-App.
Okay, die ist es schon mal nicht.
Wo ist denn...
Das habe ich unter Linux gemacht, Leute.
Das ist nicht unter Windows.
DHL, DPD,
Versandtracker, Windows Forms. Nein.
Scanner, Windows Forms ist es auch nicht.
Haben wir auch schon Detektor.
Wo ist denn das?
Wow.
Wir haben noch eine...
Eine Web-Application 2 haben wir noch.
Die hatten wir gerade, glaube ich.
Warum machst du jetzt 2007 auf?
Sag mal,
unordentlich as fuck.
Das ist...
Okay, das ist die komische Blazer-App.
Die wollen wir nicht.
Web-Application.
Leute, das war unter...
Das war eine eigene
VM. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das war in einer meiner ganz normalen Linux-VM,
wo wir das gemacht haben.
Also unter Windows ist es nicht.
Hätte ich den Kram mal damals ge...
Proggers?
Nee, das ist das Hardware-Ratool.
Ist das unter Windows?
Was? Echt? Nee.
Na gut, wenn das unter Windows gewesen wäre,
dann müsste das hier dabei sein.
So, das muss...
Da sind sogar Sachen von 2018 dabei.
Mit 2019 haben wir nur...
haben wir nur ein paar Sachen.
Wo hab ich die...
Das ärgert mich jetzt.
Wo hab ich hier mein Tool hin?
Hab ich das vielleicht gelöscht?
Hab ich das mal irgendwann gelöscht?
Aus Versehen?
Okay, wo könnte das noch sein?
Vielleicht hier im Stream?
Okay, Find.
Ich will jetzt aber hier kein Find machen,
weil ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin,
was da alles vielleicht irgendwo drauf war,
wo ich das mal sehen will.
Aber auch mit dem Find kann ich machen,
sieht man den halt nicht.
Find.
Komm, wir suchen jetzt mal nach hier.
Nach nem...
Wir suchen mal alles hier.
Also Corona ist es schon mal nicht.
Ah, Download Twi...
Moment.
Suchst du das Tool,
das du auf Fiverr neu programmieren lassen wolltest?
Korrekt.
Weil ich gucken wollte,
was die Inder daraus so machen.
So, das hier war's nicht.
Das, da haben wir gerade reingeguckt,
das war das falsche, ne?
Twitch Chat, genau.
So, was haben wir da oben noch zu bieten?
Das ist es nicht.
Im Trash?
Äh...
Actions?
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes.
Downloads Twitch.
Das ist, das ist aber, glaube ich,
das ist das, was der Inder programmiert hat.
Watcher, ist das für die Webcams?
Was auch immer Remapper sein soll,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Dann hab ich ein Net3,
da kann ich mein Gramma gescheit benennen, ey.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht die neu aufgesetzte Folge.
Ähm...
P.P.Ga-Board hieß das, genau.
Genau, P.P.Ga-Board hieß das.
Wo ist das P.P.Ga-Board?
Ha.
Ist weg.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das P.P.Ga-Board denn ist.
Nein, das hab ich nicht gesucht.
P.P.Ga.
Warum ist das...
Ich lösche nie was.
Warum soll ich ausgerechnet das gesucht haben?
Na gut, mehr...
Warum soll eine Fuzzy-Search mehr finden?
Das ist ja im Prinzip schon...
Contains, ja.
Oh, oh,
spackt der Stream.
Oh, Leute.
Oh je.
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Okay.
Unity Media.
Äh, Vodafone.
Vodafone in 20.
Ich hab den Scheiß echt gelöscht.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich lösche nie so...
Ich lösche nie Programme,
nee, den Telekom-Anschluss hab ich nicht mehr als Fallback.
Ich lösche nie Programme.
Aber das P.P.Ga-Board ist weg.
Na, das programmier ich heute bestimmt nicht noch einmal.
Sibaro, haben wir noch den Stream im Archiv?
Irgendwo?
Das hab ich unter Linux gemacht, Leute.
Ich bin mir da ziemlich sicher.
Das hab ich unter Linux gemacht.
Ziemlich sicher.
Okay.
RIP.
Anscheinend hab ich's weggeschmissen.
Das hab ich's auf jeden Fall vor ein paar Monaten ge...
...der so schlau bin.
Ja, schlau bin ich auch schon.
Streamer-Fragen-Tool.
30.06.
Woher wisst ihr das?
Woher wisst ihr das denn?
Hab ich das auf GitHub gepusht?
Nee, oder?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, so wie ich mich kenne.
Hab ich das...
Hab ich das auf GitHub?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Näääh.
Fuck.
Wann hab ich's gemacht?
30.06.
Was?
Nein!
W...
The fuck?
Hier?
Projektdatei drinne.
Hier.
Ah.
Ich hab's doch unter Linux gemacht.
Sag ich doch.
Ah.
Net 3.
Das hatten wir doch gerade gefunden hier.
Ah.
Benamung.
Big Brain Benamung, Leute.
Net 3.
Huge name.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Da ist es.
Huge.
Geht das überhaupt?
Ich muss mal kurz alle Fragen löschen.
So, ihr müsst jetzt mal
Edwupplos irgendwas schreiben.
Oh, es funktioniert, Leute.
Ich find's geil, wenn...
wenn Zeug, was man gebaut hat, funktioniert, ja.
Das gesamte Archiv auf meinem Nass.
Ah, yes.
Sehr schön.
Also, hätte ich den Kram ordentlich benannt...
Hahaha.
Aber, oh Leute, wir sind...
sind wir gut drauf gekommen, oder?
Ja.
Net 3.
Hahaha.
Ups.
TF, das wollte ich jetzt nicht aufmachen.
Warum hab ich den Kram so ultra-pepega benannt?
Ähm.
Das Tool hat Better-Twitch-TV-Support, wenn man sich nen Browser-Plugin installiert.
Ich hatte mir mal ne...
Es gibt nen Browser-Add-on, das macht quasi alles, ähm, jegliches HTML macht's die E-Mails.
Ja.
Ähm.
Und....
Äh, wie schaut es jetzt bei meiner Heizung aus?
Die funktioniert jetzt, seitdem der Technik-Kurs da war.
Richtigen Sechs-Header für die Programme.
Ja.
Naja.
Ahhh.
Jetzt bin ich ja froh.
Okay.
Wo krieg ich Glo-Papier her?
Das fragen sich nicht joh..
Fragst nicht nur du dich grade.
Heizung.
Sieht gut aus.
Achso.
Ich wollte euch ja...
Also.
Ich habs ja vorher noch nicht mitgekriegt.
Ich habe euch jetzt ja erzählt was für ein Programm wir gerade am basteln sind ähm.
Dieses Routenoptimierungs-Zeug für Installateure.
Jetzt, weil es jemand vorhin gefragt hat
Interessiert das noch mehr, was ich da
Am basteln will mit meinem Kollege zusammen
Dann kann ich es euch
Nämlich mal zeigen, da muss ich aber
Irgendwie die Uhr unkenntlich
Machen, da sage ich gleich was
Zu
Okay, wie mache ich das jetzt, ohne dass ich euch
Die Uhr zeige
Okay, lass mal, probieren wir mal, Moment
Neues Inkognito-Window
Browser Fullscreen
Äh, das ist mir zu gefährlich
Wir machen das jetzt
Anders, Capture
Window Capture
Äh, Chrome
Yes
Excellent, ich meine, dann sieht man jetzt
Ein bisschen was nicht, ne
Aber wir werden es überleben, wobei
Wisst ihr was, wir machen es einfach so
Da ist es zwar ein bisschen gestreckt, aber was soll's
Excellent
So
Okay, ähm
Sieht aus
Also, dann zeige ich es euch mal
Mache Balken drüber, ach was, wozu
Oh, Taskbar
MonkaS
So
Huge
Ja, es ist nicht so wild, wenn ich das leake, dann schalte ich das einfach aus
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache
Ich mache jetzt einfach so, gebe die Uhr ein
Excellent
So
Jetzt kann ich wieder einblenden
Ha
Also, es sieht ein bisschen komisch langgezogen aus
Weil der Browser jetzt nicht ganz
Seitengedingst ist
Also, sind übrigens keine echten Kundendaten
Nur mal so zur Info, ne
Also, wer sich jetzt fragt, wer denkt, das sind echte
Das ist alles
Alles Fake
Ähm, das ist alles Fake
Also sprich
Es ist kein Leak
Ähm, das wird beim Starten vom Programm
Automatisch random generiert
Und zwar mit
Ähm
Nicht Faker
Es ist aber so ein Faker-Klon
Und zwar mit Bogus, genau
Mit Bogus, das generiert Fake-Fake-Daten
Achso, ihr seht es jetzt gar nicht, ne
Ihr könnt es ja gar nicht sehen, WTF
Ich habe es euch gerade im anderen Browser gezeigt
Aber ihr seht ja gar nichts
Ähm, so, zumindest
Also, was man jetzt alles machen kann
Ist folgendes
Ähm, das hier ist ein
Also, mit folgender Technik haben wir das Ganze gebaut
Das ist
Ähm, .NET Core im Backend
Das ist Vue.js im Frontend
Vue.json im Backend
Das ist Vue.js im Backend
Das ist Vue.js im Frontend
Als Gui-Dingsbums-Kram hier
Und, ähm
Noch ein paar andere Sachen
Aber ich erzähle jetzt nicht alles
Nur so grob
Wollt ihr das verkaufen?
Wir haben das teilweise sogar schon verkauft
Die Idee ist entstanden, weil ein alter
Ich glaube, aus der Schule kennt er den
Der, mit dem ich das mache
Der kennt den aus der Schule
Und der hat jetzt einen Heizungs
Ähm
Bauerladen
Und die haben halt sowas gesucht
Da haben wir gesagt, wisst ihr was, sowas könnte man, sowas könnte man doch eigentlich programmieren, ja.
Jetzt haben wir hier so tolle Leute drin, wie Friedrich Grabbe und sowas zum Beispiel.
So, und was man jetzt machen kann, das ist jetzt aktuell einfach nur Prototyp, was man machen könnte.
Das heißt doch nicht, dass das am Ende, am Endeffekt so bleibt.
Also was man machen kann, ist natürlich einmal hier, man kann natürlich schön suchen.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal gucken will, wenn man weiß, ah, ich habe einen Kunden, der heißt Grabbe,
dann kann ich hier nach Grabbe suchen, stelle fest, fuck, ich habe mal ganz schön, ich habe sogar Achmed Grabbe am Start, ja.
Müsst ihr euren Arbeitgeber darüber informieren, wenn ihr das braucht und verkauft.
Äh, gute Frage, nächste Frage.
Naja, ich habe ja eine Firma und das weiß mein Arbeitgeber auch.
Ja, also ich habe Achmed Grabbe, ähm, haben auch zur Not noch hier Danny Grabbe.
So, man kann auch, man kann natürlich dann auch noch suchen nach, ähm, keine Ahnung, nach KIE2.
Ach nee, das geht gar nicht. KIE2.
Okay, ich habe das Suchen zur Kundennummer funktioniert noch nicht.
Ähm, zumindest was das Coole an dieser Data Table ist, ja, also wenn wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel gucken wollen,
wer so alles einen Wartungsvertrag hat, kann man das hier filtern nach Wartungsverträgen
und dann kann man gucken, okay, ähm, bei wem steht denn in nächster Zeit mal wieder eine Wartung an.
Dann kann man das nämlich sortieren nach Wartungsverträgen.
Ich habe da mal einen Dollar vorhin gemacht und nach, ähm, wer mal demnächst wieder dran ist.
Und man sieht auch, das Ganze ist auch hier ziemlich schnell.
Also da ist jetzt nix, großartige Ladezeiten oder sonst was.
So, da stellt man fest, ah, okay, hier, also bei, bei, bei Roman Kleis und bei Femke Hessler, was auch immer das ist,
was benutzt ihr für ein Backend? Das ist .NET, ähm, ASP.NET Core 3.1 oder was das aktuelle ist.
So, also, also, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, ähm, das hier mal, ich meine, ich wäre jetzt lieber zu Frederik Krabbe gegangen,
aber, äh, wir gehen jetzt mal zu, zu, äh, ähm, wir wissen jetzt, dass bei denen demnächst, äh, Wartung ansteht.
Hier Vito Holzdeppe zum Beispiel.
Wenn wir sagen, ah ja, der Vito, den müssen wir mal besuchen, dann kann man sagen, okay, mit dem machen wir jetzt einen Termin aus
und mit, mit Leo Geier machen wir einen Termin aus.
Und mit, äh, Nikita Maxen machen wir einen Termin aus.
Und dem und dem und sonst was.
Und mit dem machen wir alle Termine aus.
Hier, Brettschneider und Eggenmüller, die brauchen auch unbedingt was.
Mehmet Peters brauchen wir auch noch, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wo er jetzt ist.
Ja, hier ist Mehmet.
Wenn ich übrigens nicht weiß, wo er ist, kann ich einfach hier sagen, Mehmet, hä?
Ich fürchte fast, ich habe meine Suche kaputt gemacht vorhin.
Ich habe nämlich an der Suche noch rumprogrammiert vorhin.
Und, ähm, die gehen irgendwie nicht mehr.
Vito, der Vito geht aber noch.
Hä?
Habe ich mich, habe ich mich vertippt eben?
Habe ich mich eben vertippt?
Weil jetzt geht er, jetzt geht er wieder.
Habe ich mich...
Okay, was auch immer.
Ne, das ist eigentlich alles too lower und, und sollte egal sein.
Gut, wie dem auch sei, also wir haben jetzt, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, es laggt.
Na gut.
Wobei, es laggt gar nicht so großartig.
Zumindest.
Jetzt haben wir das hinzugefügt, haben gesagt, hier, mit denen machen wir jetzt alle, machen wir alle, äh, Termine aus.
Äh, dann kann man sich noch die, die Informationen zu den unterschiedlichen Kunden angucken.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich sage, hier, da ist hier Alessa, äh, nee, wo, wo, wo ist Frederik Grabbe?
Ich brauche Frederik Grabbe.
Wo ist Grabbe?
Grabbe.
Ja, also.
Danny Grabbe, wen haben wir hier?
Friedrich.
Friedrich Grabbe.
Also Friedrich Grabbe, der hat, ähm, der hat seine Adresse geändert.
Ja.
Die ist, der wohnt jetzt nicht mehr.
Der wohnt jetzt nicht mehr in Kuledenburg, sondern der wohnt jetzt woanders.
Ähm, oder hat eine andere Telefonnummer, dann kann man das hier updaten.
Man hat noch den Verlauf von vergangenen Terminen, dass man nachgucken kann, was da ist.
Ja, übrigens, Friedrich Grabbe hat Lutz75 at Gmail.
Klingt furchtbar logisch, ne?
Da hast du die History, sprich, äh, was für Termine man bei dem hatte und was man dort für Wartungsarbeiten gemacht hat.
Das läuft gerade auf dem Server.
Da hab ich ja auch die Urlau ausgeblendet.
Ähm, übrigens, wenn ihr noch coole Ideen habt, könnt ihr, könnt ihr ja mal was zu, was zu sagen.
Wie gesagt, das hat bis jetzt noch den ersten Kontakt nicht, äh, mit der Realität noch nicht überlebt.
Ja, und dann hinten kann man noch ein paar Notizen reinschreiben, was man, was man haben will, so bla bla bla bla.
Und dann kann man hier oben speichern.
Äh, das Speichern-Icon hab ich kaputt gemacht.
Das Speichern an sich funktioniert eigentlich.
Das Speichern-Icon hab ich kaputt gemacht, weil ich hab mir gedacht, hey, es wär doch cool, ähm, wenn das Speichern-Icon nur aktiv wird, wenn man was geändert hat.
Jetzt hab ich das Speichern-Icon auf inaktiv gestellt.
Allerdings hab ich die Logik verkackt, dass es sich beim Editieren von einem Feld wieder auf aktiv stellt.
Naja, ähm, übrigens, wenn ihr, äh, pre-noob kann ich gleich was zu sagen.
Schickt das Ganze nochmal mit AdWubLores, äh, dass ich das in meinem Tool gelockt hab, dass ich die Fragen nicht übersehe.
Also, falls ich Fragen vergesse, ne, AdWubLores davor schreiben, gut ist.
So, man kann auch die Kunden taggen, wenn man will.
Wenn man zum Beispiel reinschreibt, hier, der Typ ist ultra-nachhaltig.
Ja, nervig.
Kann man zum Beispiel reinschreiben, so nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung, äh, komplizierte Anlage oder irgendwas, können die Leute reinschreiben, was sie wollen.
Jetzt zeig ich euch mal was richtig Cooles, wenn man die Adresse, wenn man die Adresse eingeben will.
Ähm, zum Beispiel, ähm, nehmen wir jetzt mal Frankfurt.
Ja, sagen wir, sagen wir, sagen wir, der Typ ist jetzt umgezogen nach Frankfurt.
Also, Friedrich Krabbe, der wohnt jetzt, der wohnt jetzt in Frankfurt.
Ähm, da kann man jetzt sagen, Frankfurt, und man sieht ja, krasser Auto-Complete, ja.
Und ich kann sogar sagen, HPF Frankfurt, und dann kommt am Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt Deutschland raus, ja.
Oder ich kann auch sagen, 60329 Frankfurt Haupt, äh, okay.
So, so advanced ist es dann doch nicht.
Hauptbahnhof, ähm, so.
Und wenn ich das jetzt anklicke, dann sagt er mir, oh, das geht nicht.
Könnte der Kunde nicht, ich, das darf sich derjenige überlegen, das ist mir vollkommen egal.
Ähm, jetzt wird man feststellen, oh.
Oh, das funktioniert gar nicht, weil, das ist keine richtige Adresse.
So, wenn man, wenn man, ähm, zum Beispiel sagt, ähm, Frankfurt, Zeil, geht auch nicht, weil es ist keine richtige Adresse.
Aber wenn man sagt, Frankfurt, Zeil 2, das funktioniert.
Also sprich, der hat sogar Validation im Hintergrund, dass man sieht, ob das überhaupt stimmt, was man da eingegeben hat.
Und das ist mal pock.
Ja, das ist mehr.
Das ist pock.
Das ist übrigens das Einzige, was wir haben, was über Google geht.
Das geht über die Google, ähm, achso, wir können mal Frankfurt, Goethe Straße, Louis Vuitton Store, zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor auswählen.
Funktioniert.
Q6 in Mannheim, wenn Q6 eine Location ist, Location Search, hab ich da recht drin.
Q6, oh doch, ja, funktioniert.
Q6 Mannheim, was ist denn Q6, bitteschön?
Nee.
Das funktioniert nicht, weil das ist keine Adresse im eigentlichen Sinne.
Sprich, da fehlt, da fehlt die Straße.
Der müsste quasi dann auch, wenn man eine Anschrift angibt, so nach dem Motto, äh, äh, Lokal XY,
dann müsste der im Hintergrund auch einen Reverse-Lookup machen.
Wie ist denn die Straße dazu?
Äh, die Karte aktualisiert sich noch nicht.
Die aktualisiert sich erst on Save.
Und on Save geht grad nicht.
Also, sagen wir jetzt mal hier, okay, was hatte ich hier?
Zeil, Zeil 2.
Antwort, so, bam.
Nimmt er, passt.
So, und das geht aktuell über die Google, über die Google Places, ähm, heißt das, glaube ich, API.
Google Places Autocomplete.
Äh, werden die Daten nur einmal übertragen oder werden die dynamisch auf jedem Such, suchen und so weiter vom Server geholt?
Äh, ich proxy das aktuell durch, durch unser Backend durch.
Also, sprich, unser Backend kriegt die Anfrage und geht dann zu Google.
Und, äh, cached rudimentär Anfragen.
Zwischen.
Nämlich mit, äh, dem, dem von skip4.net, ne, Poly, das ist, äh, so, so, so ein Extension für den HTTP-Client, ähm, der kann auch ein bisschen caching.
Aber nur sehr rudimentär, also super advancede Geschichten cached er nicht.
Ähm, und Google APIs sind schweineteuer.
Wieso nimmst du doch nicht gleich Google Maps?
Weil, Google Maps, erstens, was ich ein bisschen doof finde, dass man den API-Key im Frontend hinterlegen muss.
Was aber kein Problem ist, da hat Google schon vorgesorgt, man kann das Ganze sperren lassen und so, das funktioniert.
Also, dass es dann wirklich nur von der gewünschten Stelle ausgeht.
Ähm, aber Google Maps funktioniert so richtig gut eigentlich nur mit Google Maps.
Och Gott, ist, ist Unity Media wieder am abkacken?
Ne, geht eigentlich gerade.
Äh, Google Maps funktioniert halt so richtig gut nur mit Google-Zeug.
Und wir machen weder die Routenberechnung, noch, äh, die, die Distanz-API oder andere Sachen über Google.
Einfach, weil Google APIs ziemlich teuer sind.
Ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob wir nicht Mapbox nehmen in Zukunft.
Ähm, aber Google APIs sind relativ teuer.
Man kriegt bei Google, glaub, 300 Euro oder so, oder 200 Euro.
Also, du hast ein relativ hohes, ähm, Gratis-Kontingent.
Aber an sich verbraucht man da schon ganz schön viel.
Und spätestens, wenn man drüber rausgeht über das Gratis-Kontingent, wird's teuer.
Ich hab allein beim Entwickeln und nur mit dieser Autocomplete-API beim Entwickeln,
hab ich, glaub ich, jetzt schon 20 Euro, äh, 20 Dollar von meinem virtuellen Konto.
Bei Google, also sprich, von meinem Bonus-Guthaben, weg.
Nur beim Entwickeln und Autocomplete ausprobieren.
20 Dollar weg.
Ja, genau. Also, Verlauf, Notizen, bla, kann man machen, wunderbar.
Man kann anschauen, ob man einen Verwartungsvertrag hat oder nicht.
Man kann Tags löschen, so.
So, ähm, jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Feature.
Ähm, also, wir haben jetzt ja hier die Leute hinzugefügt.
Äh, übrigens hier Mike Krabbe.
Mike Krabbe möchte auch unbedingt noch einen Besuch abgestattet kriegen.
So, und jetzt hat man die...
Wie man hier gesehen hat, hinzugefügt.
Sprich, die Kunden haben hinzugefügt.
Und jetzt lassen wir mal eine Route berechnen.
Wenn man jetzt hier auf diesen Routenberechnungs... diese Art Warenkorb-Dings geht.
Zack.
Dann kommt man...
Auf das... äh...
Was ist denn das hier?
Warum hört da die Karte einfach auf, Alter?
Ähm...
Zumindest kommt man auf einer Karte raus, wo man schon mal...
Ah, ich weiß warum.
Ich weiß warum.
Ich weiß warum daneben eine Lücke ist.
Ich habe vorhin ein Leafland-Plugin ausprobiert, was einem die Route als Vorschau hier nebenan zeigt.
Also sprich, erste Station Frankfurt, zweite Station das, dritte Station das, vierte Station das.
Deswegen, ich glaube, habe ich die Karte noch nicht richtig eingerückt.
So, und was man hier schön sieht ist, das ist jetzt die Route, die er berechnet hat, optimal, um die ganzen Kunden anzufahren.
Und zwar, wir fahren los von Frankfurter Main.
Dann fahren wir hier lang.
So, dann fahren wir hier hin.
Der erste Kunde kommt dann in Lauben.
Der nächste kommt in Oberostendorf.
Dann kommt der nächste in Jesenwang.
Äh, Steinhörig.
Was es nicht alles für Dörfer gibt, ja.
Ähm...
Eiting.
Und dann geht es hier weiter hoch nach Gieses.
Und dann nach Chemnitz.
Und dann nach Nienhagen.
Und dann wieder zurück nach Frankfurt.
Und das ist nicht die optimalste Route, weil die optimalste Route an sich gibt es ja nicht.
Ähm...
Und nicht so ohne weiteres.
Aber das ist eine recht optimale Route.
Und das macht er im Hintergrund halt...
Das ist eine ziemlich lange Tour, ja.
Und das macht er im Hintergrund halt für die ganzen Sachen.
Aber ich kann es dir mal zeigen.
Wir können auch mal ein bisschen...
Ich weiß übrigens nicht, wo das Maximum ist.
Wir fügen jetzt einfach noch mal jede Menge Leute hinzu.
Ups.
Und gucken, ob das Ganze dann funktioniert.
Ähm...
Ach, komm.
Wir gucken...
Oh, scheiße.
Ich gucke mal, wie viel funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel funktioniert.
Ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert.
Also, 23 Haltepunkte.
Bäm.
Geht.
Huge Routenberechnung.
Es ist so voll, dass man noch nicht bei den ganzen...
Dass man das überhaupt sieht.
So, man sieht jetzt schon, die Routenberechnung wird ein wenig komplizierter.
Wo passiert die Routenberechnung?
Ähm...
Aktuell nicht bei uns auf dem System.
Aber...
Ähm...
Wir benutzen eine Kombination aus, ähm...
OpenStreetMaps, OpenStreetMapsRouting, diese OpenStreetMapsRouting-Maschine und ein weiteres Open-Source-Projekt von GitHub.
Weil das sehr viele Sachen kann, was beispielsweise Google Maps nicht kann.
Was zum Beispiel die Google Routing-API nicht kann, ist, ähm...
Multimedia?
Hä?
Was die Google Routing-API nicht kann...
Ist, äh...
Zeitfenster.
Also sprich, du kannst...
Die Google hat zwar so eine Route-Optimization-API.
Aber was man nicht machen kann, ist, dass man sagen möchte, hey...
Ähm...
Ich muss um 5 Uhr da sein und um 8 Uhr da.
Das könnte ja Einfluss auf die Route haben und im Zweifelsfall sorgt es auch dafür, dass es überhaupt nicht möglich ist.
Ja, wenn er sagt, hey, du kannst nicht da sein und eine Stunde später da.
Die Route funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Ähm...
Das Open-Source-Tool kann das.
Ja, und das ist eine Mischung aus der...
Aus Open-Street-Maps, der Open-Street-Maps...
Dieser Open-Street-Maps-Routing-Maschine und...
Ähm...
Einen weiteren Open-Source-Tool, was die...
Das Routing für uns macht.
Sollte das nicht ordentlich funktionieren, wir können immer...
Immer jederzeit umsteigen auf Google Maps und Google.
Sag mal, hängt bei euch der Stream auch manchmal?
Obwohl ich nicht keine Paketverluste oder sonst was hab?
Ja.
Das ist das, was wir gerade...
Was wir gerade programmieren.
Mehr gibt's da ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht zu zeigen.
Termin und Berichte gibt's noch nix.
Ähm...
Ja.
So, dann mach ich jetzt mal wieder zu.
So.
Da sind wir schon ein bisschen dran.
Ähm, seit...
Seit ungefähr einer Woche oder so oder zwei Wochen.
Aber wir machen halt nicht so viel dran.
Nehmen wir mal wieder ein bisschen.
Also, ich denke...
Ich denke, das wird ganz nett.
Ähm...
Er hat das dem Typ viel zu billig verkauft.
Aber insofern finde ich's nicht schlecht, wenn es quasi das erste...
Das erste Projekt zu unserer...
Unserer Kollaboration ist.
Ähm...
Und vor allem, nachdem ich absolut keine Erfahrung mit Routing habe und...
Und solche Dinger zu betreiben, ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn derjenige, der das benutzt, am Ende da auch ein bisschen...
Kooperativer ist.
Als jemand, der einem permanent auf den Sack geht, wenn's nicht funktioniert.
So.
Okay.
Ähm...
Gucken wir mal, ob das Tool meine Fragen...
Die Fragen mitgeloggt hat.
Ah, sehr schön.
Guckt mal hier.
Also.
Klaubelt Hüttimons.
Kennst du eine Software, die virtuelle Maschinen...
Wobei, wir gehen erstmal noch mal kurz das durch, was...
Was damit...
Was mit dem...
Mit dem...
Äh...
Tool, was ich grad gezeigt hab, zu tun hat.
Ähm...
Hat die Seite ein responsive Design?
Ja.
Hab ich jetzt nicht gezeigt?
Wo hostet ihr das?
Auf einer eigenen Kiste.
Aber nicht bei uns, sondern...
Äh...
Halt...
Gemietet.
Ja.
Aktuell läuft's bei DigitalOcean...
Auf einer popeligen...
Äh...
Zwo Kern...
Zwo Kern und...
Und 8G oder so...
VM.
Einfach, weil's die einfachste Sache war.
So.
Ähm...
Schönes Projekt, muss ich sagen.
Ja.
Was ist denn groupservice los?
Ja...
Danke.
Nice.
Also, ihr hatte responsive design auf...
Ich kann...
Ich kann dir zeigen, so ungefähr, wie's aussieht.
Beautify Data Table.
Die kriegen Zugang da drauf, Ja?
So ist was geplant.
Der muss sich das nicht selbst hosten.
Ähm...
Also, man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen, wie die Tabelle aussieht.
Wenn das Fenster klein genug wird, dann switch die Tabelle in so einen View hier.
Also das ist soweit responsive wie es funktioniert.
Wie kein Container.
Vielleicht.
vielleicht vielleicht ja aber für so kleinkram bringt das nicht so wirklich
weil du musst ja dein container zeug irgendwo drauf laufen lassen und da
kannst du dir jemand klar du kannst du ein kubernetes in asia holen aber wozu
für eine sache vielleicht lassen wir es auch in einem container laufen später
aber wir brauchen ja noch ein bisschen mehr als ich fände ich fände schon ganz
cool wenn wir das auf dem eigenen linux server laufen lassen können weil auf
den linux server muss ja noch das ganze openstreetmap openstreetmaps drauf
openstreetmaps-routing und das open source programm für für routen berechnung
das kommt allerdings in container oder ist teilweise schon im container und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass wir es auch so machen werden dass wir dann pro
domain beziehungsweise pro wie auch immer es dann benutzen sollte ob das
überhaupt was wird steht die änderung in den stern ja muss man mal gucken was da
rauskommt am ende
dass wir da
einen eigenen container machen wahrscheinlich sogar wahrscheinlich
sogar aktuell läuft das deployment über github actions das ist sehr praktisch
deswegen haben wir uns auch letztens im stream angeguckt das ist sehr praktisch
ich push das einfach bei uns in master branch ins git und da dauert es
zweieinhalb minuten dann baut er das projekt auf github als standalone dotnet
core projekt und als frontend view frontend view cli projekt
und scps auf den server rüber und starren ein server neu also den dienst neu nicht
den ganzen sauber das heißt ich muss einfach nur master pushen da
funktioniert okay also hat die seite ein responsive design platz haben wir
geklärt kann es einfach dass die kunden direkt hier war eine gute idee hatte mal
Hat das irgendwas übersehen?
Ah, nee, hier. Das wollte ich
eh noch beantworten.
Kannst du ein Tool, um
Backend-Calls während der Frontend-Entwicklung zu machen?
Also,
ich habe jetzt alles lange gedauert, bis ich
darauf gekommen bin.
Ehrlich gesagt, nicht so wirklich.
Ich habe die Frage auch am Anfang erst
falsch gelesen. Ich habe das so interpretiert,
weil ich gerade erzählt habe, wo es um
Fake-Datengenerierung geht.
Ich habe das am Anfang gelesen wie Fake-Datengenerierung.
Willst du ja gar nicht.
Du willst keine Fake-Daten generieren.
Du willst quasi Fake-Antworten haben
von deinem Backend.
Also quasi, du willst gar kein Backend haben.
Du willst so tun, als hättest du ein Backend.
Oder im Zweifelsfall
ein Mini-Backend,
wo du ihm sagst,
gib Fake-Zeug zurück.
Ehrlich gesagt, nee.
Ich habe aber letztens
irgendwo mal
einen Webcast geguckt.
Ich gucke ja immer abends auf dem Tablet irgendwo einen
Webcast geguckt.
Da hat einer was erzählt
zu...
Ähm... War das das?
Das könnte das sogar gewesen sein.
Oder...
Ich glaube, das war das.
Hm.
Bin ich mir jetzt einmal sicher,
ob das das gewesen ist.
Habe ich aber noch nichts mitgemacht.
Just Funktion... Mag sein.
Ähm, ich habe es nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe nur letztens ein Video zugeguckt.
Und ich glaube, das war das.
Ähm...
Wo er irgendwie gezeigt hat, dass er quasi
Backend-Calls macht, ohne ein Backend zu haben.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall interessant zu wissen.
Also, falls du was findest,
sag ruhig nochmal Bescheid. Würde mich auch interessieren.
Ich habe es leider... Sonst hätte ich dich gar nicht
so lange auf irgendeine Antwort warten lassen.
Ich habe es am Anfang falsch interpretiert.
Nämlich mit Fake-Daten generieren.
Sonst hätte ich gleich was dazu gesagt.
Es gibt... Eins muss man ja sagen.
Was heute in JavaScript aktuell ist,
ist morgen in JavaScript schon wieder out.
Aber trotzdem gibt es viele coole
neue Sachen in JavaScript.
Ich habe beispielsweise letztens was gefunden.
Ähm...
Was heißt gefunden? Letzten. Das ist schon ein bisschen länger her.
Gibt es auch schon. Gibt es auch schon
drei Jahre oder so.
Ähm...
Das ist eine Library, wie man
quasi blockende Aktionen
im UI
anblockend
machen kann. Weiß nicht, wie ich das anders erklären soll.
Also sprich, wenn man beispielsweise
ein Array hat, was man sortieren will
oder filtern will.
Ähm...
Hier haben wir zum Beispiel.
Da gibt es ja die Möglichkeit...
Also aktuell hast du...
Du hast drei Varianten.
Wie du das machen kannst in JavaScript.
Entweder du machst das
synchron.
Dann blockt dein GUI.
Das funktioniert nicht standardmäßig. Nö.
Wenn du Array sort machst
in JavaScript, dann blockt dir dein ganzes
GUI, bis es fertig sortiert ist.
Weil Eventloop-Grab.
Na, was heißt Grab? An sich ist so funktioniert
der Kram halt. Ja.
Die zweite Variante ist, asynchron zu machen.
Sind Webworker. Das ist quasi...
Da können wir auch mal ein Beispiel zu machen.
Da gibt es auch von Mozilla ein gutes Beispiel.
Die zweite Variante sind Webworker.
Das ist so eine Art
Multithreading im Browser. So eine Art.
Ja. Es ist ein bisschen
hässlicher, wie ordentliches
Multithreading in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache.
Aber...
Moment, die meine ich gar nicht. Die haben ein schönes
Tutorial. Aber das funktioniert
ganz gut.
Das funktioniert ganz gut. Man muss ein eigenes
JavaScript-File anlegen.
Was dann quasi nichts anderes
macht. Also man legt
ein eigenes JavaScript-File an, was dann von
einem Background-Thread ausgeführt wird.
Und zwischen Main-Thread und... also zwischen
UI-Thread und Background-Thread
macht man hier mit PostMessage
schickt man Aufgaben hin und her.
Das ist relativ easy.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Und da kann man einen Background-Worker
machen, der quasi hier wartet
auf OnMessage.
Und dem postet man dann vom
Frontend aus, sag mal, einen Array
mit 5000
Einträgen.
Lässt den sortieren und der
postet das zurück an den Main-Thread.
Und der Main-Thread sagt in seiner OnMessage
Funktion, Methode
A ist da, ich
binde es jetzt ins Frontend ein. Also das ist die erste
Variante, wie man was... Und ich finde mit
die sauberste Variante, wie man was
asynchron in JavaScript machen kann, über
WebWorker.
Ein bisschen doof ist es, wie auch generell
bei allen Multithreading-Geschichten,
wenn
das, was man hin und her schiebt,
recht groß ist. Da muss man sich fragen,
inwieweit das was bringt. Also wenn man da jetzt irgendwie
einen Array hat aus
keine Ahnung, 50.000
JavaScript-Objekten und das schickt man
da rein, sortiert es und schiebt es wieder zurück.
Vielleicht
muss man gucken, was besser ist.
Ja. So und die dritte
Variante ist, man macht das
sortieren, was normalerweise
das UI blockt, macht man
in kleine Häppchen.
Teilt man in kleine Häppchen auf. Also sprich,
wenn man ein Array aus 5000 Elementen hat,
was man sortieren möchte,
dann sortiert man einfach immer nur
in hunderter Schritten. Und am Ende
halt nochmal einmal drüber.
Und dann blockt das UI auch nicht,
wenn man schnell genug ist.
Beziehungsweise, wenn man es in kleine
Häppchen macht. So. Und das ist
eklig, sowas von Hand zu programmieren.
Da muss man nämlich ganz viel Set-Timeout
und Geschiss machen. Und da
ist, da zeigt
JavaScript wieder sich von der komplett hässlichen
Seite. Und das Ding ist echt
praktisch. Das macht das nämlich für einen.
Wenn man jetzt ein Array
filtern will, also sprich nach
Elementen, die einem gewisses Kriterium
entsprechen, dann kann ich einfach sagen,
hier, S-Link-Filter, schieb hier mein Array
rein, steck ich mein Array
rein mit 50.000 Elementen.
Und der macht
dieses ganze Set-Timeout
und S-Link-Zeug für mich.
Und am Ende krieg ich ein fertig gefiltertes
Results-Array raus,
was ich dann weiterverwenden kann.
Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Serverseitig, ja gut,
die Variante hab ich jetzt gar nicht erwähnt.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Das ist ja logisch.
Das ist klar.
Das ist nie verkehrt.
Serverseitig kann man es auch machen.
Ist wahrscheinlich sogar nicht schon gut.
Das ist die schönste Variante von allen.
Sorgt nämlich auch dafür,
dass man das auf irgendwelchen
Kack-Android-Telefonen machen kann.
Oder auf älteren iPhones,
die halt nicht alles unterstützen,
geschweige denn, so viel Power haben,
da irgendwie im Frontend ruckelfrei
50.000 Elemente zu sortieren.
Brennhub, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich würde es eigentlich prinzipiell
serverseitig machen. Ich finde es eigentlich
eigentlich zu serverseitig am schönsten.
Aber serverseitig,
je nachdem, was man es kostet,
kostet mich halt Ressourcen.
Kleinseitig kostet mich nichts.
Und manchmal
ist es halt kleinseitig
einfach
einfacher.
Weil du musst nichts hin und her schicken.
Und nichts implementieren.
Du hast die Daten eh schon da.
Und so ein kurzes Filter ist halt schnell gemacht.
Hängt ein bisschen davon ab,
was man vorhat.
Mir das Streamen hängt nicht.
Hast du dir die
Open Root Service Auto?
Ja, habe ich.
Ähm, habe ich.
Also erstens, Open Root Service
selber hat, äh,
ist komplett kostenlos.
Hat aber eine relativ geringe
Beschränkung, was man machen darf.
Also, nein.
Äh, Platz.
Die haben nämlich nur,
die haben nämlich nur, ähm,
1000 Geocoding Requests am Tag.
Und, ähm,
wo fällt denn das Auto,
wo fällt denn das Auto komplett drunter?
Ich habe mir das angeguckt.
Ist es Directions?
Ist es Directions und der Auto komplett?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe es mir angeguckt.
Es war relativ gering, was man, was man an, an, an, ähm,
ähm, Requests zur Verfügung hat.
Ähm, das nächste Problem war,
dass die Suche nicht gut war.
Ich habe die Suche mal ausprobiert von, äh,
OpenStreetMaps.
Nomina, Tim heißt das bei denen.
Habe ich die Suche ausprobiert.
Und, da hat man, da sieht man mal,
da sieht man mal, äh, hallo?
So, wenn man jetzt in deutscher Lesung sucht nach B,
Bär, da würde man eigentlich hoffen,
man findet Berlin.
Aber man findet nicht Berlin,
man findet Bär, Batsch, Blub, Blub, äh, Blub, Blub.
Findet man, ne?
Ähm, oder in, in Timbuktu.
Bär.
Tombuk, Tombuktu.
Bär, Tombuktu.
Timbuktu, Mali.
Alles klar.
Das ist natürlich das, was ich finden will,
wenn ich nach Bär suche.
Und das Ding ist auch nicht besser,
wenn man Country auf, äh, Deutschland festlegt,
dann findet man auch ganz, ganz merkwürdige Sachen.
Und das Problem hatte ich mit allen Autocomplete APIs,
außer Google.
Gibt es einen Import? Ja, es gibt einen Import, einen CSV-Import.
Das liegt daran, weil das einzige Format,
was das Tool, was die aktuell verwenden,
das ist irgend so ein Crap Bloated Windows Ding
mit 30.000 Knöppen dran,
was die aktuellste Kundendatenverwaltung verwenden.
Das einzige, was das exportieren kann, ist CSV.
Und es gibt einen CSV-Import.
Aber ich find den Ansatz eh besser,
dass wir das für die importieren,
weil dann ist es egal, in welchem Format,
dann können wir das umfuddeln, sodass es funktioniert.
SAPUI5, ich hab damit noch nie was gemacht,
klingt aber auf jeden Fall eklig.
Das hatten wir.
Kennst du eine Software,
die virtuelle Maschinen auf Hardware möglich macht,
die keine Hardware-Virtualisierung unterstützen?
Ja, aber das ist nicht schnell.
Also wenn du wirklich,
wenn du hardcore andere Architekturen emulieren willst,
also zum Beispiel,
wenn du ARM unter x86 emulieren willst,
oder sowas,
dann kannst du Cuemo nehmen.
Es gibt Leute,
die nehmen Cuemo,
lassen darauf einen Raspbian laufen
und kompilieren sich dann für einen Raspberry Dinger,
weil es angeblich schneller wäre.
Das halte ich aber für ein Gerücht.
Die ARM-Emulation in Cuemo ist unendlich langsam.
Da ist es einfacher,
man kauft sich einen Raspberry Pi 4
und lässt den eine Woche laufen,
bevor das da drüber fertig ist.
Aber ja, also wenn du ein System suchst,
was komplett jegliche andere Architekturen emulieren kann,
auf einer Hardware,
die es sonst nicht kann,
dann Cuemo.
Aber wenn es darum geht,
dass du einfach nur eine x86-VM auf einem x86-System brauchst,
dann nimm einfach VMware Workstation oder VirtualBox.
Keines von beiden braucht Hardware-Virtualisierung.
Das funktioniert auch ohne.
KVM braucht, glaube ich, Hardware-Virtualisierung.
Oder braucht KVM?
Oder braucht KVM nur Hardware-Virtualisierung
für PCI-Pass-Through?
Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, KVM braucht generell Hardware-Virtualisierung.
Aber VMware Workstation sollte auch funktionieren
ohne Hardware-Virtualisierung.
Die Software gibt es ja schon in Zeiten,
wo Hardware-Virtualisierung überhaupt nicht angesagt war.
Ja, VMware Workstation without VTD heißt der Kram, glaube ich, oder?
VTD?
Ne, wie heißt er?
Intel Hardware-Virtualisierung.
Wie heißt denn der Kram nochmal?
VT?
VTX?
Also scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich versuche, ein Windows-VM-64-System ohne Hardware-Virtualisierung aufzulassen.
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
das habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Also VMware Workstation müsste prinzipiell funktionieren,
weil das hat auch lange vor Hardware-Virtualisierung,
bevor es das überhaupt gab, funktioniert.
Ausprobieren.
Ich könnte es mal ausprobieren,
indem ich meine Hardware-Virtualisierung abschalte,
aber das kann ich jetzt gerade nicht machen.
Es müsste funktionieren.
Aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir da auch nicht.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, noch nie gemacht.
Also seit es 64-Bit oder so ist,
seit es 64-Bit-OS gibt und ich 64-Bit habe,
habe ich, glaube ich, auch Hardware-Virtualisierungen drin.
Und alle sagen SAP und nicht SAP.
So, haben wir auch.
Was sagst du zu Windows 10 2004?
Noch nichts?
Ich habe es mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Was gibt es denn da Neues?
Was gibt es denn Neues?
Zeig mal her.
Äh...
Succells...
Data...
Ist das in Linux?
Oder ist das in Windows?
New Cort...
Oh!
New Cortana!
Geh weg!
Ja, Tribula hat recht, Alter.
Okay, also was gibt es noch?
Also Windows 10,
New Version of Cortana.
Microsoft macht sich das Leben selbst mal wieder schwer, ne?
Sie haben Cortana...
Was ist denn mit...
Also ich benutze Cortana überhaupt nicht,
aber was ist mit Microsoft eigentlich wieder los, ja?
Ich meine, jetzt haben sie Cortana rausgebracht,
das war wohl auch ganz gut
und hat funktioniert.
Jetzt kann es wieder Sachen nicht.
WTF?
Ähm...
Zugucker?
Gar nicht,
weil ich kein Multi-Display-Setup unter Linux habe.
Ich habe meine Linux vor allem,
die ist ja logischerweise hier auf einem Bildschirm.
Auf dem anderen Bildschirm ist ein anderer Rechner dran,
unter Windows.
Und auf der Arbeit habe ich einen curved 4K,
fragt mich nicht, 32, sonst was Zoll.
Da sind quasi zwei Bildschirme in einem.
Das Problem habe ich aktuell gar nicht.
Einzige was ich mache,
mit X-Render am Anfang den Notebook-Bildschirm,
beim Boot den Notebook-Bildschirm ausschalten.
So, dann wird Cortana auf Android und iOS eingestellt.
Gut, das kann ich verstehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Cortana auf Android und iOS überhaupt benutzt wurde.
You can move and resize Cortana Windows...
Moment, das konnte alte Cortana nicht.
Cortana konnte man nicht resizen?
Und das ist jetzt ein krasses neues Feature,
oder was, dass man Cortana resizen kann?
Okay, Windows, Windows halt.
Small Indie Company, ja.
Die sollten sich mit Blizzard zusammentun,
dann sind sie vielleicht nicht mehr so small und indie.
Ayaya Wallpaper.
Okay, you can set your preference...
Cortana juckt mich ehrlich gesagt nicht die Bohne.
Finally, Cortana has improved.
Productivity Skills, E-Mails...
Wer schreibt noch E-Mails?
Coming Appointments...
Gut, braucht kein Mensch.
Subsystem for Linux 2.
Windows Subsystem for Linux.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich eher ein Linux Subsystem for Windows,
dass es mal ordentlich funktioniert
und wir alles drauf machen können, was wir wollen
und ein bisschen Spiele unter Windows verwenden können.
Nutzt du virtuelle Desktops?
Ja, sowohl unter Windows, wie man hier sieht.
Sowohl unter Windows als auch unter Linux.
Überall benutze ich virtuelle Desktops.
Virtuelle Desktops, beste.
Okay, das finde ich gut, dass das neue WSL am Start ist.
Ich finde es merkwürdig, dass man jetzt von einem
eher Vine-artigen Ansatz mit quasi
AP-Übersetzung zu VM gewechselt ist, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Pflege einfach einfacher für Microsoft.
Das ist gut.
Notepad Improvements.
Ernsthaft.
Super, Leute.
Notepad wird besser.
Yeah, voll. Endlich.
Line Numbers.
Hu hu.
Boggers.
Gibt es auch nicht virtuelle Desktops?
Ja, das habe ich euch schon oft genug erzählt.
Das einzige, was an virtuellen Desktops nicht virtuell ist,
ist eigentlich der Desktop.
Weil, wie ihr seht, der Desktop ist überall der gleiche.
Also Notepad Improvements.
Notepad kann jetzt größere Schriftarten.
Wahnsinn.
Microsoft ist hier der Innovator schlechthin.
Windows Search Improvements.
Das könnte tatsächlich nicht schlecht sein.
Weil die Windows-Suche ist so...
ähm...
So, naja...
So geht's so. Aber...
Schön ist die Suche nicht.
Moment.
Search Experience in File Explorer
is now powered by Windows Search.
Moment.
Heißt das etwa,
dass wenn ich hier suche,
das nicht die gleiche Suche ist,
wie wenn ich hier suche?
Was? Warum?
Ey, das war mir überhaupt nicht klar,
dass das was unterschiedliches ist.
Ja, anscheinend.
Das sind zwei verschiedene...
Das ist...
Typische Windows-Logik.
Pipp...
Na, Windows-Pepega am Start.
Okay.
Microsoft has improved search index
to reduce impact on performance.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht,
warum sich Microsoft
so schwer damit tut,
eine ordentliche Suche
auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Ich mein, unter Linux gibt's
ein paar Tools, die funktionieren
und die sind zwar nicht die absoluten
Bleeding Edge Tools
und es gibt auch bessere Sachen,
aber ich mein, ein Find
hat keinen Index
und durchsucht einfach alles
und funktioniert.
Und ein Locate braucht nen Index
und geht halt auch einfach.
Es ist nicht das...
die fanciesten Tools
und haben auch nicht die meisten Optionen,
aber die gehen einfach.
Ich versteh gar nicht das Problem.
Alternativ gibt's ja auch noch
zig weitere Varianten für Linux,
was Source-Code-Suche angeht,
Volltext-Suche,
ähm, allen möglichen Dinger.
Ja.
Grab, äh, in Kombination
vielleicht noch mit einem Fuzzy Finder.
Es gibt zigtausend Varianten
und die funktionieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was so schwer ist,
das in Windows auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Okay, Sandbox.
Äh, Sandbox haben wir schon mal ausprobiert.
Find ich gut, dass es jetzt quasi
eine offizielle VM-Lösung gibt.
Die, äh, für Leute, die quasi
Schiss haben, sich Virus einzufangen.
Ich mein, die beste Lösung
ist immer noch, ähm,
Linux VM.
Aber, dass sowas in Windows dabei ist, find ich gut.
Ähm, aber das find ich gut.
Mein, oh,
Virtual Desktops renamen.
Okay.
Ich hatte bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt
wenig Bedürfnis,
meine Desktops in Windows zu renamen,
aber wenn das geht, ist gut.
Das ist ne Windows-VM in Windows, ja.
Task Manager.
GPU Temperatures.
Okay, das ist gut.
Disk, das ist auch gut.
Das sind so Änderungen, wo ich mich immer frage,
warum waren die nicht schon vorher lange da?
So Sachen, die ich selbstverständlich
erachten würde, kommen ja immer da jetzt irgendwie
irgendwann rein und es fällt einem auf,
fuck, das konnte Windows ja noch gar nicht.
Brauch ich Windows 10 Pro für die Sandbox?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kann jetzt googeln,
aber wissen tue ich nicht.
Accessibility.
Eye Control.
Hat das wirklich was mit dem Auge zu tun?
Okay, das ist für Leute, die wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr richtig die Hände verwenden können.
Äh, den Vorleser,
den verwenden wir auch. Nicht.
Den verwenden wir bloß für so Sachen.
Omega Oil.
Das ist der einzige
Kram, wofür wir den Ansager
verwenden.
Und für alle anderen Sachen verwenden wir
verwenden wir
unseren koreanischen Ansager.
Easy as fuck.
Get lecked, get lecked,
easy as fuck.
So, das ist mir alles
ziemlich wurscht.
Finally, da ist nur Text pieces.
indicator settings account security was auch immer
ach das gibt es ein setting für ja endlich gehen wir fort das will ich
ausschalten restart apps gibt es das jetzt schon dass das geht mir nämlich
auf den sack wenn sich sachen automatisch starten das muss weg 360
no scope bitte ja moment moment moment wo habe ich denn hier so haben sie alle
durch optional features management ja endlich endlich endlich fliegt für das
alte grie raus was ist was ich mit dem desktop los ganz schön dazu lol desktop
sieht mir gar nichts drauf
ja endlich endlich endlich fliegt für das alte grie raus was ist was ich mit
Das würde mal Zeit, weil aktuell hat ja Windows so zwei Sachen.
Windows hat Apps and Features und hat Turn-Off-Windows-Features.
Total wir.
Schau mal nach Coronavirus-Challenge.
Nein, danach schaue ich nicht, weil ich weiß, was das ist.
Und da habe ich schon wieder am Komplettverstand der Menschheit gezweifelt,
als ich Coronavirus-Challenge gesehen habe.
Und die Coronavirus-Challenge ist sowas für die absoluten Braindead-Zoomer-Generation.
Die dreht sich darum, dass man öffentliche Toiletten, Türklinken und Rolltreppengriffe ableckt.
Das ist die Corona-Challenge.
Die Leute sind einfach komplett gestört.
Das ist echt Braindead.
Und danach stecken sie ihre Oma.
Und die Oma stirbt und dann heulen sie rum, weil sie dumm sind.
Welche Linux-Distribution benutzt du?
Manjaro mit i3-WM.
Das juckt mich auch nicht.
Cloud-Download.
Bluetooth und Connected Devices.
Network Settings.
Network Settings Page.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Alter Microsoft, was ist mit euch los?
Hier kann man immer noch nichts einstellen.
Man kann immer noch nichts einstellen.
Das juckt mich doch immer.
Das ist überhaupt nicht.
Was für Schwachsinn.
Typische, typische, das ist so ein typisches Microsoft-Gui hier.
Warum Manjaro nicht direkt an-Linux?
Hm.
Weil Manjaro einen ordentlichen Installer hat.
Und weil Manjaro die Repos zwei, drei Wochen ein bisschen zwischenbuffert.
Und man nicht den allerletzten krassen Bleeding Edge-Scheiß abbekommt.
Äh, das wäre gut, wenn Windows mehrere Monitore mit unterschiedlichem Refreshrate ordentlich könnte.
Ich bilde mir aber schon ein, ich bilde mir ein, dass das schon seit Jahren geht, weil ich hatte mal die, meine Capture-Card ran am zweiten Display-Ausgang mit 60 FPS und der Hauptbildschirm lief auf 144, das hat funktioniert.
Maus, Cursor, Settings, iNoise, Imo-, was, Kao-Moji, aha, jetzt kann man Kao-Moji verwenden.
Uwu, Owu, was, Dictator Support, was ist da los?
Er soll mal in Nordkorea bleiben.
SwiftKey, Type Intelligence in More Languages, was?
Oh, mein SwiftKey?
Ist SwiftKey nicht das zusätzliche, das zusätzliche Android-Keyboard?
Das habe ich auf meinem Amazon-Tablet.
Das ist jetzt Microsoft?
Okay, na dann.
Das war's.
Okay, man muss sagen, es tut sich nicht viel, ja.
Was mich interessieren würde, ist, ob Windows 2004, also Windows 10 2004, eine sehr unglückliche Versionsbezeichnung, muss man sagen, in dem Fall, dass Windows 10 2004, ist das wieder so eine Neuinstallation unter der Haube oder ist das ein Update?
Ich hoffe, das ist ein Update, weil bei einer Neuinstallation unter der Haube muss ich wahrscheinlich wieder mein gesamtes System entschlüsseln und neu verschlüsseln.
Da habe ich immer keinen Bock drauf.
Wobei es letztens, ab letztes Vollinstallation-Update, hat es mit der Verschlüsselung funktioniert, ohne dass ich es entschlüsseln musste.
Ja.
So, was haben wir noch für Fragen?
Wir sehen hier.
Taskbar, Taskname, was?
Ich meine von wegen Automatisierung meine ursprüngliche Frage.
Äh, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Italien, ich hoffe, wir aus Italien bestellen.
Das war mal ein Big Brain Move.
Hatten wir.
Äh, das ist noch nicht ganz klar.
Was alles reinkommt, beziehungsweise wie man es überhaupt umsetzen kann.
Wir haben keine Straßennamen.
Das sollte funktionieren.
Solange es eine richtig echte Adresse ist, dann funktioniert das.
Hast du von Wir vs. Virus gehört?
Ja.
Ähm, ich war auch auf der Seite drauf und ich habe nicht genau gecheckt, um was es ging.
Das einzige, was ich verstanden habe, ist, dass es ein Projekt ist.
Quasi ein Programmierprojekt, wo man Projekte vorschlagen kann.
Oder.
Was ist denn das?
Was zum?
Was ist das?
Ich habe einen Mauszeige-Highlighter installiert.
Unter Linux.
Ich wusste bis heute gar nicht mehr, dass ich...
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, ich habe das mal installiert.
Ihr, ihr...
Windows-Taste C.
Den habe ich mal installiert, weil ich mir gedacht habe, wenn ich mal Streams aufnehme oder so.
Ähm, man Sachen zeigen will, dann kann man Highlighten, kann ich sagen.
Hier, guck Leute, hier.
Was eigentlich ganz praktisch ist.
Habe ich komplett vergessen wieder.
Ja, also hier geht es wohl irgendwie darum, dass man Projekte programmiert, die wohl, gerade bei Corona, die quasi die Bevölkerung gut unterstützen.
Aber so ganz habe ich nicht gecheckt, ehrlich gesagt, worum es dabei ging.
Bundesregierung startet Hackathon gegen Corona.
Darf man eigentlich Corona sagen oder muss man es irgendwie cooler aussprechen?
Corona oder so.
Oder wie letztens auf Twitter getrendet ist, Coronavirus.
Mit Virus.
Ich muss mal gucken, dass ich übrigens keine Subs verpasst habe.
Brick hat gesubbt, dankeschön, falls ich übersehen habe.
Ähm, Schrödinger hat gesubbt, Ander hat gesubbt.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs, Leute.
Heftiges Hacker-Bild.
Was hat er denn auf?
Ich würde das Bild gerne groß machen und gucken.
Ah, yes, alles klar, jetzt erkenne ich sofort, was er aufhatte.
Alles klar.
Ich erkenne auch nicht mal, ob es Windows ist.
Ich meine, von der Taskbar hier unten könnte es Windows sein, aber was Corona?
Das klingt ja richtig beknackt.
Hauptsache Bier und Pizza.
Vor allem hat er eine Tastatur, ja eine Mini-Tastatur.
Niemand würde das so machen, das aussieht ja wie eine ganze Tastatur an.
Du machst die Hände vom Maus-Tastatur weg, futterst was, putzt sie kurz ab und machst weiter.
Ansonsten flutscht ja ein Kleiner nach fünf Minuten Tastatur.
Genau.
Also, man kann das irgendwo einreichen.
Ich frage mich jetzt, was da rausgekommen ist oder ob das jetzt noch, das startet jetzt
dann amnächst.
Hier, hat gestartet.
YouTube-Channel.
Alle Herausforderungen.
Wow.
What the fuck.
Wollen sie aber wissen, wie kommunizieren wir mit dem, ja und weiter, wie kommunizieren
wir den Status in Supermärkten.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage.
Wie kriegt man das auf die Reihe, dass man, bevor man hingeht, weiß, was verfügbar ist.
Da müssen aber die Supermärkte mitmachen.
Krankenhäusern.
Wie können die, was die Kapazitäten, auch eine interessante Frage.
Wie können wir kreativ werden in den Seiten von Social Distancing?
Da wollten wir uns doch ganz am Anfang mal das hier angucken.
Das Social Distancing Dashboard.
Also sprich, da sieht man, wie gut die Leute distanced sind.
Heute bisher Trends.
Oh.
Nice.
Die Leute sind viel distanzierter.
Covid Companion App.
Was?
Okay, da haben jetzt 30 Milliarden Sachen was vorgeschlagen.
Ja, habe ich vor einer Weile gesehen und da war es für mich recht unsüchtig, um was
es da geht.
Aber mittlerweile ist es eigentlich klar.
Aber ich habe da immer nicht so Energie, mich in sowas einzubringen, ja.
Okay, was?
Was machen die da so?
Typisches Neuland-Internet, ey.
Typisches Neuland-Internet, Alter.
Ist das nicht peinlich?
Ich meine, okay, es geht ja um was gemein, nütziges, okay, ich will nicht mich zu sehr
flamen, aber...
What the fuck, Alter?
Was soll ich das angucken?
144p.
Denn das Schlimme ist ja, das ist ein 720p.
Ach so, du meinst bei DH, ja.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
What?
Sahen die anderen, sahen die anderen Videos auch alle so aus?
Ne.
Da siehst du doch normal aus.
Was?
Kommt dazu.
Zwar auch nicht absolut High-End-Technik, aber...
Slack-Session mit euch und deswegen dauert es gerade noch ein bisschen.
So viele Grills am Start.
Naja, die Quali, die andere Quali ist auch nicht so viel, nicht so viel besser.
Was ist denn das für ein Chat-Tool?
Ist das irgendwie Slack?
Ne, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Hangouts.
Das ist Hangouts.
Oh Gott.
Das, das war, das haben wir mal, das, dass man immer noch Hangouts verwendet, äh, Hangouts
haben wir vor, vor 10 Jahren verwendet auf YouTube manchmal.
Hast du eigentlich noch deine Duckie-One-Tastatur?
Klar, verwende ich auf der Arbeit jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag.
Wollte mal kurz gucken, ob es hier in Österreich, ob es in Österreich noch Klopapier zu bestellen
gibt.
Regina!
Toilettenpapier.
Oh, yes.
Innerhalb 3 Wochen.
What the fuck.
Deren Slack hat aktuell 22.000 User.
Boah, nicht schlecht.
Ihr müsst eine Tastatur mitbringen.
Nö, müssen wir nicht.
Aber die Tastaturen, die wir bekommen, sind nicht so doll.
Deswegen habe ich mir eine eigene Tastatur mitgebracht.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Da haben wir gerade schon.
DM.
Schickt nicht nach Deutschland.
Und im deutschen TM-Shop gibt es wahrscheinlich nichts mehr, hm?
Lieferzeit.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Lieferzeit.
Ist aber, man, derzeit nicht lieferbar.
Warum kaufen die eigentlich alle wie verrückt Toilettenpapiere?
Dir bleibt hier gerade nichts anderes übrig, als mitzumachen.
Nice Day.
Nicht verfügbar.
4-Jahr.
Pfirsich-Po, feuchtes
Toilettenpapier. Ah, yes.
Wenn man es braucht.
Noch wenige
Stück verfügbar.
Liefern die auch nach Deutschland?
Ist ganz schön teuer,
4,29.
Arbeit zu mit Docker und zu Karo auf der Arbeit,
ja.
Mach ich. Kann man nach Deutschland bestellen?
Oh, RIP.
Ne, doch nicht.
Zur Kassa.
Sagt man das in Österreich so?
Geht nach
Deutschland?
Ah, geht anscheinend nicht.
Na toll.
In solcher Zeit ist ein
Frohums ein smartes WC.
Ja, aber ich brauch trotzdem noch Klopapier.
Kennst du das Video, wo der Opa den ganzen
Schlecker leer kauft?
Ne, hast du mal einen Link?
Ich hab noch nie mit
APIs gearbeitet. Wie würde ich
eine, beispielsweise
PHP-API mit
beispielsweise Java verbinden?
Äh, überhanden.
HTTP? Ganz einfach.
APIs sind ja
nix anderes, wie ganz normale
Webaufrufe, also wie ganz normale
HTTP-Aufrufe.
Nur halt nach einem gewissen Schema,
sodass es für die Daten, die man hat, logisch ist.
Was streit beim Hamsterkauf?
Okay, okay,
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Streit beim Hamsterkauf.
Wow, die schreien
da schon voll rum.
Oh, die schreien da schon voll rum.
Ich frag mich, was passiert...
Ja, ich wollte auch gerade sagen,
ich frag mich, was passiert, wenn man die Zombies anrücken, ja.
Ei, ei, ei.
Oh, fuck,
die drehen ja voll am Rad, ey.
Die drehen ja voll am Rad.
Du hast ein anderes geschickt?
Ja, du hast
ein Video von 2012 geschickt.
Die drehen ja voll am Rad, ey.
Ich bin der nächste Haufen.
Haha,
bist du bekloppt
oder was?
Scheiße, Alter.
Die sind ja voll am eskalieren.
Was geht mit denen ab,
Alter? Das ist ja nicht mehr normal.
Wo ich halt echt...
Also, wer heutzutage
jetzt gerade im Supermarkt
arbeitet, ey, der hat echt
die Arschkarte.
Alter.
Ich find's ja auch geil, wie die, ne,
keiner traut sich, was zu sagen.
Das ist so geil, ne?
Es traut sich keiner, was zu sagen
und danach, wenn die Situation
wieder geklärt ist,
ähm, sprechen sie aber mal nach Hausverbot aus.
Das können sie sich aber so nicht bieten lassen.
Sprechen sie doch mal nach Hausverbot aus.
Was spasten alle, auf voller Linie, alle spasten.
Die einzige, die mir echt leid tut, ist,
ähm, die Frau, die in dem Supermarkt
arbeitet.
Eine Güte.
Leute, macht so wie ich,
also in dem einen Fall, also generell
macht's nicht so wie ich, aber in dem Fall
Klopapier, macht's wie ich,
kauft den Kram im Internet bei irgendeinem
Großhändler. Dann habt ihr zwar einen riesen
Haufen Klopapier, aber ich mein,
so what? Ihr braucht eh Klopapier.
Klopapier ist nix, was irgendwie schlecht wird.
Und selbst wenn ihr ein bisschen zu viel Klopapier
habt, ist auch nicht wild, ähm,
dann habt ihr halt für ein halbes Jahr Klopapier,
wenn ihr euch so ne, wenn ihr euch
Parollen beschaut.
Na, also, und es ist viel,
viel einfacher zu planen, zu liefern,
alles, wenn man das online bestellt.
Schau dir das andere
Video auch noch an.
Okay.
Was sind das andere Videos?
Das andere Video, das hier.
Das ist aber von 2012, das ist schon alt.
Ausnahmezustand am Morgen
in dieser Schleckerfiliale in der
Wilhelmsdorfer Straße.
Das Rentner-Ehepaar Thiele kauft den Laden leer.
Das ist von 2012,
ah.
An die 100 Packungen
Toilettenpapier und Küchenrollen
werden gehamstert.
Boah, es geht mit denen ab, ey.
Der Lager wird geplündert.
Die Kunden seht heiß, scharf auf den Rabatt.
Schlangen bilden sich vor dem Geschäft.
Nicht alle dürfen gleichzeitig rein.
Viele Kunden müssen warten, bis sie
an die begehrte Ware rankommen.
Dann gibt es kein Halten mehr.
Alles wird gekauft, weil es billig ist.
Thiele hat inzwischen das...
Da würde ich nie mitmachen bei so nem Scheiß, ey.
Ich...
Ich kauf eh generell sau...
Also sau wenig in Läden ein.
Ich bestell das meiste online und immer, wenn ich's brauch.
Ey, Mann, jetzt paar Klopapier
bleibt mir in der Nase übrig.
...ganze Toilettenpapier im Laden gebunkert.
Nun will er auch noch an die Lagerbestände ran.
Seine Frau soll helfen.
20 Pakete...
Küchenrollen, 20 Pakete noch dazu.
Oh, was geht ab, ey?
Nee, mich kannst du mit Videos nicht rickrollen,
weil ich hab in meinem Chat einen Vorschau,
äh, was hinter YouTube-Videos...
...videos steckt.
Das heißt, ich kann weder rickrolled werden,
richtig,
noch kann ich debated werden mit MonkaTost-Videos.
Und da holen sie sich jetzt ein Taxi, oder was?
Ja, klar.
Aber das zahl ich für die Karre von hier bis hier rüber nach Hause.
3,50 Mark, die nehm ich 10 Mark und schon ist es wieder offen.
Ist das fake?
Oder ist das echt?
Thiele hab ich nicht mehr.
Das sind die letzten 24.
Habt ihr ein anderes Toilettenpapier?
Andere Toilettenpapier haben wir auch hier.
Ja, ja.
Sechs müssen da hoch.
Sechs müssen da hoch, dass 30 sind.
Und 20 Mark Küche rollen.
Ja, welche Torte?
Das ist scheißegal.
Das ist auf ihren Arsch.
WTF, was ist das für ein Spaß?
Oh nee, da ist eine Axtel drin, da hat sie gesagt.
Das ist das Küche rollen.
Ja.
Der packt da hier oben hin.
Da kommt ja noch was neben.
Ich mein, der hat's gut.
Der hat bestimmt noch Klopapier von damals übrig heute,
wenn er noch lebt.
Der Taxifahrer kann das machen.
Ja, das ist ein Schwanz, ja.
Das ist ein Hochjahr.
Naja, ich muss aus Weimar fahren.
Ich muss mir auch mal.
Die Stimme von dem Typ erinnert mich an irgendwas.
An irgendwas erinnert mich der...
Ah.
Ich weiß nicht.
Hört mir grad nicht ein.
Haben Sie denn genug Platz zu Hause für das...
Ach, kommt doch ein Keller runter.
Das reicht doch für ein ganzes Jahr,
dann bräuchte ich ja nicht Innenkuchen hier hin.
Das ist ja eins, hab ich davon noch nicht gefunden.
Hm.
Und dann nochmal noch die anderen.
Mach dir einen anständigen Blick.
Ich hab Bus und 160.
50 Euro bei mir.
Jetzt weiß ich, jetzt weiß ich, jetzt weiß ich, wie der anhört.
Der hört sich wie...
Frag nicht, warum ich so Videos kenne, ja.
Der hört sich wie der Klatscheier-Typ an.
Kennt den Scheiß noch jemand?
Nicht.
Der Taxifahrer wird verrückt.
Das ist schockend.
Nee, nee.
Das meint alles.
Nein, das zeigt...
Nee, es ist kein Toss-Video.
Es ist aber eigentlich ein ziemlich dämliches Video.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren.
Da ist es irgend...
Da erzählt halt irgendein Typ...
Von Klatscheier.
Richtig dämlich.
Müsst ihr mal auf YouTube suchen.
Richtig dumm.
Ist weder Toss noch sonst was, aber eigentlich richtig dämlich.
Ja, gut, aber...
Ja, der Opa kauft halt...
Der Opa kauft halt einen Schlecker leer.
Ist doch gut.
Kann er doch machen.
Der hat halt heute noch Klopapier.
Ist doch gut für ihn.
Da muss er...
Oh, jetzt kein Klopapier mehr.
Sag ich das neue Doom raus?
Sag ich das...
Sag ich das neue Doom mittlerweile raus?
Ah, seit gestern.
Da weiß ich doch, was ich spielen kann dann.
Alles.
Oh, ich muss euch mal den bescheuertsten...
Wartet mal.
Ich hab einen ultra dämlichen Aluhut-Kommentar unter YouTube entdeckt.
Den muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Ich muss den Pluskarten auf meinem Handy suchen.
Warum sagt man nicht immer noch Handy?
Hier.
Ja.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich den finde.
Das ist der Aluhut-Preiskommentar aller Zeiten.
Mist.
Find ich nicht.
Hm.
Dann lese ich es euch vor.
Weil ich hab's nur...
So blöd wie ich bin, ich hab's nur gescreenshottet.
Ich hab's nur gescreenshottet.
Und...
Das war ein Video, wo es mal wieder um das beliebte Thema Klimawandel ging.
Das ist ja so ein Thema, da sind mittlerweile...
Sobald da auf YouTube ein Video zu kommt, da hast du...
Da hast du...
Schlagen sich die Leute...
Schlagen sich die Leute die Köpfe ein.
Und ich find's immer ganz lustig, teilweise, was da für Leute auftauchen, ey.
Ähm.
Muss ich euch mal...
Muss ich euch mal vorlesen.
Ich...
Wie gesagt, ich hab nur einen Screenshot von.
Ähm...
Also ein bisschen Kontext.
Das war wohl ein Video.
Geht eine Stunde 33.
Ich war hier bei 11 Minuten.
Irgendwas von den Grünen oder so.
Keine Ahnung, ich erkenne den Videotitel nicht mehr.
Zumindest...
Der YouTube-Kommentarmann, der erklärt uns jetzt hier, der YouTube-Kommentarmann,
der erklärt uns jetzt quasi, wie die Welt funktioniert.
Und zwar...
Ähm...
Es gibt...
Ich leh...
Ich leh auch nichts mehr vor.
Es gibt keine physikalische...
Also, Zitat, ja?
YouTube...
YouTube-Kommentar.
Es gibt keine physikalischen Gesetze, nur physikalische Einbildungen.
Alles Placebo-Effekt.
Flugzeuge stürzen ab, weil Menschen daran glauben, dass sie abstürzen.
Flugzeuge fliegen, weil Menschen daran glauben, dass sie fliegen.
Das ist genauso wie mit Windows.
Würde die Menschheit sich nicht von Apple veräppeln lassen, das ihnen vorgaukelt, dass Windows instabil ist, würde ein Windows-PC niemals abstürzen.
Das ist alles eine perfide Verschwörung der Wissenschaft.
Apple gleich Newton.
Also Physik.
Gleich der Apfel.
Gleich der Adam.
Und Eva aus dem Paradies geworfen hat.
Gleich Satan.
Wissenschaft ist also ein Produkt des Teufels, um die Menschheit zu verführen.
Dabei ist alles so einfach.
Ich glaube, also bin ich.
Glaube ich nicht, bin ich nicht.
Und weg bin ich.
Du Scheiß, Alter.
Ey, nee.
Vielleicht Troll.
Aber wenn du dir die anderen Kommentare angeguckt hast...
Unter diesem Video, die waren alle so bescheuert.
Die waren alle so bescheuert.
Ich war früher auch jemand, der immer gesagt hat, wenn jemand was total Abstruses gepostet hat, habe ich auch immer gesagt, Troll.
Aber Leute, das können nicht alles Trolle sein.
Da sind legit Posts drunter, die einfach nur so abwegig für uns sind, dass wir gar nicht dran glauben können, dass das wirklich echte Posts sein könnten.
Aber ich fand, ich fand die...
Ich fand die, ich fand die, äh...
Ich fand das schon nicht schlecht.
Mit Apple gleich Newtonphysik, der Apfel, der Adam, Eder, und gleich Satan.
Also Apple gleich der Teufel.
Aber der war ein guter Typ, der hat's drauf gehabt.
Die Herleitung war stark, ja.
Hast du das Video von diesem Leon zu Corona gesehen?
Nein, ich...
Deutsch ist YouTube, ich gucke nichts mehr.
Ich gucke nichts mehr.
Ich kann mir kaum was angucken.
Das Einzige, was ich mir in Letz...
Was ich mir in Deutsch...
Nee, stimmt nicht.
Ich gucke mir schon noch ein paar Sachen in Deutsch an.
Aber das meiste gucke ich mir mittlerweile auf internationalen Englisch, Englisch an.
Ähm...
Ich gucke mir beispielsweise hier...
Auf YouTube gucke ich mir für...
Für Werkzeug...
Für Werkzeugtests gucke ich mir noch manchmal Videos auf Deutsch an.
Von denen hier.
Die machen das nicht schlecht.
Auch wenn die Videos und Thumbnails übelst nach Clickbait aussehen, aber...
Die, äh...
Videos sind nicht übel.
Ähm...
Und ein paar andere Videos...
Ein paar andere deutsche Channels gucke ich mir ab und zu auch noch an.
Aber das meiste gucke ich mir international YouTube an, weil ich YouTube Deutschland nicht ertrage.
Und ich blicke nicht mal durch.
Was auf YouTube Deutschland so abgeht.
Es gab mal eine Zeit, da kannte ich gefühlt jeden mit 50k plus Abos.
Heute...
Kriege ich irgendwo was empfohlen oder irgendeiner postet was.
Ich gehe drauf, sehe ein Video von einem Typ, von dem ich nichts gehört habe.
Bisher nichts gesehen.
Nicht wusste, dass er überhaupt auf dieser Welt existiert.
Gehe auf den Channel.
850k Abos.
Und ich bin dann so...
Den kann es doch nicht erst seit gestern geben.
Ich blicke nicht mal durch auf YouTube.
Aber YouTube Deutschland interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Meiste Trash-Videos.
Ja, ist so.
Mal gucken, ob mir die Fragen hier mal irgendwann hinterher kommen.
Warten wir.
Mit wer ist der alte Kanal?
Altes Windows 15...
Ah, Big Brain.
Ist das so ein Tick von dir?
Ja.
Habe ich schon.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Sind das die kleinen...
Mit Sicherheit sind da welche dabei.
Ja.
Weil es gibt ja auch immer noch Leute, die der Meinung sind, dass Corona generell nur
reiche, weiße Männer betrifft.
Hatten wir auch letztens.
Aber betrifft es uns schon mal zum größten Teil nicht.
Ja.
Genau.
Weil wir sind, wir sind wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil weiße Männer oder Männer
auf jeden Fall, aber reich sind wir nicht.
Also, kann es uns schon mal nicht treffen.
Safe.
Corona, safe.
Ganz einfach ist es.
Kennst du eine Möglichkeit, wie man die virtuellen Desktop von, auf einen Monitor begrenzen
kann?
Nee.
Kann ich nicht.
Wieso tippst du bei der Uhr immer eine Eins rein?
Ich tippe manchmal sogar.
Vierer-Blöcke Eins rein.
Wer kann so schnell Einser-Vierer-Blöcke tippen, hä?
Was benutzt du zum Verschlüsseln? Bitlocker? Nee, Veracrypt.
Die einzige Software aus Frankreich, die ich, glaube ich, je verwendet habe.
Manchmal beantwortest du Fragen kurz, indem du direkt antwortest.
Wir wissen dann aber nicht, weil du...
Ich versuche das meistens vorzulesen, aber es kann sein, dass ich das manchmal vergesse.
Corona mit der Shotgun, ja, auf geht's.
Also, ich bin in einem Team, was schaut, wie man schnellstmöglich quasi digitale Klassenzimmer digital unterrichtet.
Für diese bewerkstelligen kann, also ist nicht nur hacken...
Ah, okay.
Also, rein vom Gefühl her, ich bin ja kein so Bauchgefühl, ja.
Ich hab mich ja... Ich kenne ja nicht so viele Produkte, aber...
Ihr wisst, ich bin kein großartiger Microsoft-Fan.
Aber ich glaube, so ad hoc, so das Einfachste, was man sich aus dem Ärmel schütteln kann,
dürfte tatsächlich Office 365 sein und Microsoft Teams hostet in Azure.
Das ist das Einfachste.
Das klingt man dreimal und funktioniert.
Ob man jetzt die Microsoft-Sachen toll findet, ist wieder was anderes, aber...
Vom Einfachheitsher gerade sollte das ganz weit oben sein, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Und ihr wisst, ich bin wirklich kein Microsoft-Fan.
Ja, Dagi-Tastatur habe ich noch.
Schnell einfach Küchenrollen in zwei.
Ja, Küchenrollen sind ja auch aus. Gibt's ja auch nicht mehr.
Ja.
Nein.
Die tägliche Aluhut... Oh, nee, nee, auf Twitter.
Twitter.
Ich hab echt genug Deppen auf Twitter gehabt die letzten Tage.
Ich könnte mein Klopapier teuer verkaufen, auf Ebay mach ich aber nicht.
Ich hab mir schon überlegt, was ich mit meinem Klopapier mache, wenn's denn dann ankommt.
Ich stapel meinen Vorratsschrank so weit wie es geht.
Ich mein, so viele sind das nicht.
6 x 9 x 8 sind 12 Packen.
12 Packungen.
Davon werde ich eine Packung dem Nachbar links und eine Packung dem Nachbarn links.
Und eine Packung dem Nachbarn links.
Und eine Packung dem Nachbarn rechts geben.
Was meint ihr, was das für eine Geste...
Das wird eine Geste sein, die dafür sorgt, dass sie die nächsten 20 Jahre meine Pakete von DHL annehmen.
Das ist vorausschauend für die Zukunft.
Die kriegen einfach beide...
Wer in der heutigen Zeit ein Packen Klopapier verschenkt, der kann nur gewinnen.
Dann vielleicht krieg ich auch immer gegrilltes vom anderen Nachbarn.
Naja, kann auch sein.
Aber bessere Geste gibt's aktuell nicht.
Das ist quasi das runde Gold, das weiße runde Gold.
Was hältst du von der Aussage, Truecrypt wäre sicherer, weil dort ein kompletter Audit gemacht wurde?
Nun ja, das stimmt.
Aber die Umstände über die Schließung von Truecrypt sind etwas mysteriös, nebulös.
Und Veracrypt muss...
Muss ja wohl ein Fork von Truecrypt sein.
Das heißt, es sollte zum Teil auch dafür gelten.
Was man natürlich nicht weiß, ob da nicht jetzt zwischenzeitlich was eingebaut wurde.
Nichtsdestotrotz halte ich es für wichtiger,
maintainede Software zu verwenden,
als Uralt-Software, die vielleicht mal irgendwann geauditet wurde.
Mal gucken, wie schnell die Seite aktualisiert.
Jetzt weiß ich später nicht mehr, welche Seite es geht.
Meinst du die hier?
Schnell.
Eins hat die.
Die aktualisiert alle drei, vier Sekunden.
Kam vor einigen Wochen mal auf.
Schauen wir uns mal gemeinsam die Einrichtung eines PXE-Servers an.
Wenn es sein muss.
Was hast du denn vor?
Ich bin eigentlich kein großartiger Fan mehr von PXE-Gebüte.
Entweder ist es irgendwelches Cloud-Zeug, was gleich von einem richtigen Image startet.
Oder man macht halt einen USB-Stick dran, wenn es ein richtiger Server ist.
Und zieht sich das dann übers Netzwerk.
PXE-Server ist immer so krasses Rumgefrickelt.
Weil, da merkt man dann, dass es irgendwie schon 25 Jahre alt ist oder 30 Jahre alt ist.
So, alle Fragen aus hier.
Haben wir es geschafft.
Haben wir alles beantwortet.
Easy.
Guck mal Leute.
Das macht mich zuversichtlich.
Wir sind jetzt bisher 2 Stunden 36 Minuten on.
Wir haben jetzt eine ganze Weile so um die 200 Zuschauer im Dreh.
Und ich hatte keinen Plan.
Was ich...
In dem Moment, wo ich die...
Ich den Stream angemacht habe.
Ich hatte keinen Plan, was ich mache.
Das macht mich zuversichtlich, dass ich mir für Streams nicht immer im Vorfeld was überlegen muss.
Irgendwie, was man großartig machen könnte.
Sondern ab und zu einfach auch mal streamen kann.
Ohne, dass man was großartig geplant hat.
PXE im Docker.
Das ist natürlich die bessere Variante.
Da muss man den Kram nicht selbst konfigurieren.
Netboot XYZ.
Das ist tatsächlich eine...
Ziemlich gute Seite.
Die kenne ich.
Das konnte man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Das ist eine ziemlich gute Seite.
Die kenne ich.
Und zwar...
Was ich euch da mal zeigen muss zu...
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das wirklich mal an.
Wofür das sehr praktisch ist.
Netboot XYZ.
Das geht auch ohne PXE-Boot.
Das ist quasi so ein Mini-Image.
Ein Mini-Image, was man auch booten kann.
Kann man seinen Boot-Manager damit überschreiben.
Beim nächsten Boot landet man da drinnen.
Das ist ein Mini-Image mit einem Menü und einem Netinstall für gängige Linux-Betriebssysteme.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Ich habe euch ja schon öfters erzählt, dass ich einen Server habe bei so einem absolut reudigen Kack-Hoster.
Bei dem da.
Das war ein Angebot von...
Also der hat ultra gute Reviews, dieser Hoster.
Das ist quasi die Creme de la Creme der Hoster.
Die definieren ihre SLAs auch eher über Downtime als über Uptime.
Das ist ein sehr guter Angebot.
Und bei denen habe ich mal einen Server gemietet für 35 Dollar Lifetime.
Also ich habe einmal 35 Dollar bezahlt vor sieben Jahren oder so.
Und seitdem ist er da.
Das Ding läuft wahrscheinlich auf dem letzten Rotz an Hardware.
Und auf dem überbuchtesten ESX aller Zeiten.
Man hat ungefähr 2 MB die Sekunde Read-Write auf der Platte.
Und das ist ein sehr guter Angebot.
Das ist ein sehr guter Angebot.
2 MB die Sekunde.
Megabyte.
Die Sekunde Read-Write auf der Platte.
Der riesen Vorteil von dem Ding ist, man hat eine statische, feste IPv4-Adresse.
Und Netzwerk ist auch halbwegs geschwind.
Der Rest ist für den Arsch.
An Dawn-Server kann ich mich noch erinnern, ja.
Die waren aber gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich meine, wir hatten da ein bisschen Probleme mit der Minecraft-Server-Performance.
Ja, aber an sich waren die okay.
Aber die hier sind richtig schlecht.
Und was ich da gemacht habe, ist, weil die bieten nur ein Ubuntu 14.04-Image oder so an.
Also richtig oldschool-Scheiß, ja.
Das habe ich installiert und die bieten keine Möglichkeit, an ISO-Boot zu machen.
So ein eigenes ISO, vor allem bei 2 MB die Sekunde ist ja auch, ne.
Und da habe ich Netboot XYZ genommen.
Habe das ausgeführt mit einem Curl.
Man macht einfach einen Curl.
Und pipet das nach DD im Endeffekt.
Und dann überschreibt es den Crab.
Und dann habe ich dann quasi über Netboot XYZ, habe ich dann mein Server rebooted.
Und dann ist es in das Menü reingegangen und da habe ich Ubuntu 18.04 oder was das war zuletzt drauf installiert.
So, und der Installer.
Ich habe noch nie im Leben eine so unglaublich langsame Ubuntu-Installation erlebt wie hier.
Wie bei denen.
Mit 2 MB die Sekunde, die Ubuntu-Installation, die habe ich abends angestoßen.
Abends.
Abends, 18 Uhr oder so.
Und morgens, am anderen Tag, als ich auf der Arbeit gesessen habe und mal reingeguckt habe, war der immer noch am installieren.
Also der hat glaube ich fast 24 Stunden Ubuntu installiert.
Das musste er erstmal schaffen.
Kann jemand zufällig ein Android für einen alten Laptop empfehlen?
Warum muss es ein Android sein für einen alten Laptop?
Android hat es mit Hardware-Unterstützung nicht so gut.
Und die x86 Android-Geschichten.
Sind auch meistens nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Wenn es ein alter Laptop ist, je nachdem, was du machen willst, kannst du dir einen Linux drauf installieren.
Oder aber Windows 10.
Je nachdem, wie alt er ist.
Windows 10 läuft erstaunlich gut auch auf ältere Hardware.
Mit Android glaube ich nicht, dass du glücklich wirst auf einem normalen Laptop.
Wie du die Corona-Cases angezeigt kriegst.
Hiermit.
Machst einen Curl auf Corona.
Also normalerweise ist da auch mehr in der Anzeige drin.
Guck.
Normalerweise kriegst du für alle Länder, den ganzen Kram.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach nur die letzten, die oberen 20 Länder ausgegeben.
Also die oberen 10, weil es irgendwie mehrere Zeilen sind.
Und das aktualisiert jetzt alle 2 Sekunden.
Jetzt haben wir quasi live Corona-Übersicht, wie es hochgeht hier.
Aktuell haben wir 22.213 Fälle.
Und heute gab es 2.365 neue.
Man hat ja unten gerade gesehen, in der Schweiz hat es aktualisiert.
Guck mal in Südkorea.
In Südkorea.
In Südkorea funktioniert es.
Die Zahlen in China glaube ich ja nicht.
China glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich denen nicht.
Die geben einfach keine Zahlen raus.
Ach, du willst Android-Apps nutzen.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, keine Idee.
Ich wollte selbst mal in nächster Zeit auf einem Raspberry Pi in ein Android testen.
Gucken, wie das so funktioniert.
Es gibt aber für ein Desktop mittlerweile halbwegs brauchbare Android-Apps.
Es gibt Android-Emulatoren, die ganz gut funktionieren.
Habe ich letztens ein Video drüber gesehen.
Eigentlich ist nur die letzte Spalte relevant.
Warum sollte das die einzige relevante Spalte sein?
Die Fallen pro eine Million Einwohner.
Was wichtig ist, wichtig ist eigentlich das hier, wie viele neue Fälle es am Tag gibt.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass das nahezu exponentiell erstmal steigt, ist das hier das Wichtige.
Äh, ich glaube, wir kriegen noch deutlich mehr Tote.
Wir kriegen natürlich mehr Tote in den nächsten Tagen, weil...
Das... das hat ja bei uns erst so richtig angefangen seit...
... einer Woche.
... eine Woche?
Max, was hältst du von Investitionen in Bitcoins?
Da habe ich ja ein Video zu gemacht.
Und im Prinzip das Fazit aus diesem Video war...
Das muss jeder selbst wissen und ich bin kein Krypto-Coin-Experte.
Das ist ZSH, ja?
Also wenn die Leute sich bisschen dran halten...
... dann glaube ich nicht, dass es so schlimm wird wie in Italien.
du schon mal erfahrung mit o v h gemacht und kannst du dir was waren das noch mal
es war ein o v h noch mal als in cloud geschichte
weißt du das wenn du das meint habe ich damit noch keine erfahrung gemacht o v h
ein haus da wieder meinte die hier wie soll ich so der bitcoin kurs wo gerade
dabei sind auch ist wieder ist wieder ganz schön runter geflutscht hier und
jetzt wieder ordentlich hoch nehmen mit denen habe ich noch keinerlei erfahrung
gemacht ehrlich gesagt was warum fragst du was du was macht die aus also warum
sollte man die kennen was haben wir da so zu bieten
ok von der vm reicht mir aus sind franzosen ja gut das ist jetzt aber kein
grund dafür warum man zu denen sollte oder
das ist weder
ein grund dafür noch dagegen ist starke ram ausstattung vielleicht könnte ich
da mal auf dem street maps zeug drauf
monka s windows
das doppelte und ganz normal eindruck schau dir scaleway an also ich habe
bisher eigentlich nur von der arbeit noch so ein bisschen habe ich eher
schon verwendet wobei er ja kein kleines haus da ist kann es halt auch vms hosten
aber das nicht sinn und zweck der sache ansonsten verwende ich eigentlich habe
schon mal Bot Welt was gemietet und ansonsten wenn ich kurzzeitig etwas
brauche dich dichten lauschen und da habe ich ja noch meinen 35 dollar
milftima
oioi o ja ja könnte ich gebrauchen
oioi oia ja könnte ich gebrauchen
oIOI o ja ja könnte ich gebrauchen give
Boah
Krasser Shit
265 GB RAM
Oh
So ein Ding könnte ich
Wirklich mal gebrauchen für ein paar Stunden
Dass ich mein
OpenStreetMaps Geschiss
Extrahiert bekomme
Wobei ich lasse es einfach auf meiner 4 HE Kiste laufen
Die hat auch 48 GB RAM
Mit Swap reicht das dicke
Haben wir gemacht
Ja Leute, oh es ist 22 Uhr
Gut, es ist Wochenende, aber trotzdem
Früher gibt es ja wieder Aufwachen Stream
Ah ja, zur Erklärung, wieso PXE
Wir müssen mal kurz hier ein ordentliches
Emote installieren
Global Twitch Emotes
Yes, excellent
Warum geht das hier nicht?
Ah, weil da keine Emotes drin sind
Gibt es schon Battlefield Clips?
Ja, ich, dieses Wochenende ist soweit
Morgen ist soweit, Battlefield Video
Morgen ist soweit
Ich hab's dir fest vorgenommen, morgen ist soweit
Ich brauch mal ne Nachricht mit nem
Mit nem Emote drinne
Ne, funktioniert nicht
Warum nicht?
Ah, hier
Hm
Ah, ich hab nicht gespeichert
Wobblords
Ne, ist kaputt Leute, geht nicht
Ah
Ah, yes
Excellent
Jetzt funktioniert was
Ähm, seit wann streamst du denn?
Seit?
2 Stunden 52, aber auch nicht mal allzu lange
Weil ich geh gleich ins Bett
Ähm, sehr schön
Äh, zur Erklärung, wieso PXE
Setze meinen Rechner gerne mal
Spontan neu auf
Da erkenne ich mich wieder
Das hab ich früher auch gerne gemacht
Und vergesse dann meist zu prüfen, ob ich
Bootsticks habe
Um dem aus dem Weg zu gehen, dann halt PXE
Aber ich scheitere da an manch Umsetzung
Und Docker ist mir völlig fremd
Ähm
Dieser Docker-Container, den sie hier vorhin gepostet haben
Irgend, äh, hier
Der hat der Chat vorhin gepostet
Der hier
Der da
Äh, ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, aber
Wie gesagt, ich hab Netboot XYZ ausprobiert
Hat wunderbar funktioniert
Und wenn das einfach nur ein Docker starten ist
Dann ist das total einfach
Mehr als das musst du nicht machen
Ich würde dir empfehlen, guck dir einfach mal ein Docker-Tutorial an
Ich mein, du bist ja eh unter Linux unterwegs
Und an so ein bisschen den Container-Basics
Kommt man eigentlich heute kaum noch vorbei
Und dann ist das einfach nur ein Docker-Basics
Guck dir einfach mal irgendwie so 30 Minuten
Docker-Introduction an
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel
Wenn man mal ein bisschen dahinter gestiegen ist
Man muss auch überhaupt nicht verstehen, wie es unter der Haube funktioniert
Sondern einfach nur, wie die Docker-Commandline funktioniert
Ähm
Und das Schöne daran ist
Dass du eben
Den Kram starten kannst bei dir lokal
Halt so
Und hast einen fertig funktionierenden PXE-Server
Und wenn du wieder weg haben willst
Löscht du den Container
Und er ist halt widerstandslos vom System wieder weg
Also das scheint mir die beste Alternative zu sein
Anstatt PXE selbst zusammen zu frickeln
Ich hab PXE schon selbst zusammen gefrickelt
Das ist nicht schön
Wie gesagt, morgen Battlefield, Leute
Morgen Battlefield
Bei mir auf YouTube
Endlich, hier
Ich hab's mir fest vorgenommen
Morgen nehm ich auf
Also, das ist bestimmt weit hergeholt
Sagt, äh
Alik
Oder Alikatzika
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wie man es bespricht
Wie man es bespricht
Oder Ali ist, glaube ich, besser
Äh, also das ist bestimmt weit hergeholt
Aber nach meiner Meinung denke ich, dass es mit Corona ausarten wird
Ich denke, die Währung in Schein oder Münzen
Wäre in naher Zukunft kein Wert mehr
Nee, das glaube ich nicht
Welches Battlefield?
Na das, wo die Leute mir die Clips für geschickt haben
Ich hab hier im Stream Battlefield Plays gesammelt
Richtig gute Plays
Und da mach ich für YouTube nen
Ähm
Nen YouTube
Nen Best of
Best of Battlefield Clips
Ja
Hat er nicht gesagt?
Hat er auch nen PXE-Server am Laufen, aber der konnte kein EFI
Äh
Moment, Moment
Sollte PXE nicht ne ganze Ecke danach kommen?
Sowohl EFI als auch
Dings, die müssen ja erstmal Netzwerk-Boot machen
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man
Muss man bei PXE
Ist bei PXE ne besondere Anforderung für EFI?
Siehst du mal, wie wenig ich damit gemacht hab
Oh, EFI-Mode
Kann das Ding auch
Ja, Tribolon, mal gucken
Wenn ich noch mehr Videos machen will, dann muss ich das sagen
Ja
Also ich würde tatsächlich für nen einfachen
Für nen einfachen PXE-Server
Würde ich tatsächlich das hier mal probieren
Also
Lass dieses ganze Unrate-Gelaber hier weg
Ja
Das hier ist das entscheidende, was du brauchst
Da
Und eigentlich brauchst du
Das kannst du weglassen
Äh
Konf
Fick
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man die braucht
Oder ob da eigentlich dabei ist, standardmäßig
Kannst du weglassen
Das brauchst du eigentlich auch nicht, wenn du das als Root ausführst
Wobei, Docker-Container als Root ist ja so eine Glaubensfrage
Das können wir mal ausprobieren
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf
PXE-Docker testen
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf
Das könnten wir wirklich mal in einem der nächsten Streams machen
So
Achso, okay
Ja, C2-Haro, ähm...
Wie gesagt, mehr kann ich da nicht zu sagen
Hätte ich mich nicht gut genug mit aus...
Oh, guck mal, Frames haben gedroppt
Frametrops sind raus
Gut, Leute, wir sehen uns morgen früh
Ich guck jetzt mal, was die Katze so macht
Ich krieg hier noch ein bisschen Futter, dass sie heute Nacht nicht rumnervt
Wobei, abends, die will ja nachts gar nichts futtern, ne?
Ähm, also nichts richtiges futtern
Die will...
Abends will die immer...
Wiskas Knuspertaschen haben
Wenn ich der abends keine Wiskas Knuspertaschen gebe
Dann, äh...
Kratzt die nach 20 Minuten bei mir an der Schlafzimmertür und will rein
Ja, so ungefähr sieht das bei meiner auch aus
Eja
So, legt sie oben auf dem Schrank hier
Da hat sie ganz schön dicke Bobbes auf dem Bild, ähm...
Okay, mach mal das Zeug weg
Also, wir sehen uns morgen
Macht's gut
See you